wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you two
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some of the
best
simon sonic motivation of all time enjoy
vision is an internal thing right it is
the world that
you want to live in right jobs was the
rebel
and he always was against big business
right um all the visionaries that we
know
have some sort of personal experience
and imagine a world that is different to
the one they live in now
and will use their businesses to help
build that world that doesn't mean
they're the only ones doing it but what
makes them a leader is they're the one
leading towards that place right so
vision has to come from you
if you're the founder of a company your
business is not the only way you do it
what if you quit your business and start
another one
it doesn't matter they should all be
contributing towards this vision
and you're not the only one doing it but
if you're the one preaching it
and you're using your company to advance
it that makes you
the leader that's why everybody copies
you but it's not about anticipating the
market trend which is an interest thing
you're asking me it's got to start with
values
the interest comes second they're
definitely there but they definitely
come
second yeah biggest risk you've ever
taken
um i completely changed the course of my
life and career when i discovered this
thing called the why i abandoned what i
was doing and said i want to do that and
people thought it was crazy they thought
i went out of business but i was so
i believed in it so much i i threw
caution into the wind
i think why has been the key my whole
life to worldwide
it's it's a little kid question that we
grow out of for some reason here's what
i've learned about mentorship
mentorship is not something you ask
somebody to do like will you be my
friend
it doesn't work like that um when you
find somebody you get along with you
share values you share beliefs you spend
time with them you get to know them you
develop trust
you take you're vulnerable with them you
open up to them and you discover that
you become friends it's what happens
you start off as simply acquaintances um
in in my experience mentorship is
exactly the same
there were people who were much more
experienced than me who had
wisdom that i didn't have and i when i
would call them
they would take my calls and when when i
would ask them questions
they would always take the time to give
me answers and
over the course of time they became my
mentors like they became my friends
and i remember one time i was with one
of my mentors ron bruder
an amazing guy and i was leaving his
house and i put my arm around him i said
you know i'm glad you're my mentor
and he looked at me and he said i'm glad
you're mine and it caught me completely
off guard and true mentorship like true
friendship is not a one-way street
it's not about one person only giving
advice to the other both people are
showing up to give
and both people are showing up uh to
learn
um but you can't ask someone to be your
mentor especially someone who's a total
stranger knock on their door
and say will you be my mentor if they
don't know you you've never met them
it's like friendship
you cultivate a relationship and if that
person is always there for you
and wants to see you thrive and succeed
and believes in you
then perhaps they will become your
mentor like making a friend
companies obsess about their competitors
which is fine tactically
which is fine for short term but long
term
most companies aren't brought down by
the competition they know about they're
brought down by the competition they
don't know about
some new emerging technology you know do
you think the music business
was paying attention to the computer
business at all of course not they were
paying attention to other music
companies
um you know myspace wasn't
focused on friends to facebook they
didn't even know facebook existed
but it's facebook that brought them down
or significantly hurt their business
right in other words if you don't even
know who your competitors are
what's the point of fixating and making
all of your business decisions based on
competitors all we're doing is reacting
reacting reacting this is why purpose
matters
it gives us a north star yes we have to
concern ourselves with our competition
from a tactical
and short-term point of view but to make
long-term strategic decisions
based on a competitive set that we don't
even know that's complete based on
technology that we don't even know it's
it's completely fully baked is madness
it's absolutely madness
right so you want to fixate on the on
the
the on the path also if you want to have
unstoppable confidence self-love and
motivation check out my 254 series
they're free
the links to join are in the description
below the skill
to hold your opinions to yourself until
everyone has spoken
does two things i would rather take the
risk
of walking out knowing that i might
get moved in a way that i've never
experienced before more
than just going to have a nice night out
and see something that i know is good
some people
see the thing that they want and some
people see the thing
that prevents them from getting the
thing that they want what do leaders
need to
do to understand the trends in their
industry better because it's very easy
to say
this is where this business or this is
where this competition this market is
going
it's actually that's what everyone else
is doing so how can you get ahead of a
trend
in the way that steve jobs was able to
look at where the puck is going so trend
data is very dangerous
because all it does is report a trend it
doesn't report if it's positive or
negative and everyone else has got it
and everybody else has got it
so for example you know kids these days
are all using
uh apps to do everything we should make
more apps
but nobody says it's healthy right in
the 1980s you needed to do cocaine to
get through the business day
you know does that that's a trend that's
a trend not really true cocaine usage
was up
in the 1980s in businesses it was if you
worked in an investment bank
yeah yeah yeah yeah no i was i was i was
definitely not doing that
so the point is the point is if the
point is it's a trend
yeah that doesn't mean we should invest
in it right so trend data is
i think the way people rush towards a
trend because they think that's where
the market is going it's very dangerous
because it's incredibly unstable
information
but you have to as a leader anticipate
where your market is going and make
three or five year plans and the way you
do it is with vision
right so for some reason somebody keeps
telling me that i
unders my publisher said this to me that
i'm good at understanding the zeitgeist
and he's wrong i have no clue
about what people are thinking all i
know is where i want to go
that's it as i said before i have a
vision of a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired to go to work feel safe
when they're there
and return home fulfilled at the end of
the day so i can make certain guesses
and predictions but things i have to do
to get there so i was living in london
and attending law school
i was becoming disillusioned with the
law i happened to be dating a girl
who was in advertising she said you
might like advertising and boom i have a
career in marketing
like i fell into it so many of us fall
into our careers and fall into our jobs
and even if we do pursue something we
want to do
sometimes it takes diversions right this
is this is what i mean by living our
lives
by accident which is we largely leave
the direction of our careers and
sometimes even our own happiness to
others our bosses
you know all of that thing so what it
means to live your life on purpose means
you understand the direction you're
heading
but you remain agnostic as to the root
most people try very very hard to plan
the route in other words what's your
plan people say well first i'm going to
work here for three years
then i'm going to quit and i'm going to
do this and then for four years and i
got the root plan
and the question is where are you going
right and that to me is what it means to
have purpose it means to have
destination right it's like waking up in
the morning and saying i'm going on
holiday somebody says where are you
going i said
i'm going on vacation i told you you're
like where are you going vacation
right um and so how are you going to get
there like well i'm taking route 95 so
you've got the route planned
but you have no destination and you see
this in companies all the time
you know why does your company exist
growth great
why are you growing why do you need to
grow what does growth mean because we're
a company we have to grow
and so they figure out all of these
paths for growth but they don't know
where they're going
i would rather someone wake up in the
morning and say california i'm trying to
get to california
and i don't care what route i take i'm
going to start down route 95 and if i
find a better route i'm going to take it
if there's traffic on route 95
i'm going to take a side road so this is
what happened in my career people kept
telling me
that i was unfocused because i kept
taking side roads i wasn't unfocused i
was going around
obstacles so that's what it means to
live a life of purpose it means
i live every single day of my life
trying to get to an end point
in my case to create a world in which
the vast majority of people
wake up every single morning inspired to
go to work feel safe when they're there
and return home at the end of the day
fulfilled by the work that they do
that is the destination i'm trying to
reach i don't know how i'm going to get
there
but i'm going to try every path i can to
get there highly highly focused that's
what it means to live a life on purpose
we're often given this advice like do
what you love
yeah like what am i supposed to do with
it yes like find your passion like thank
you
like great like i don't know what to do
tomorrow
for me passion is the result of
something
right so if you work hard for something
you don't believe in
that's called stress and if you work for
so hard for something you do believe in
that's called passion so it's finding
the belief it's finding the cause it's
finding the purpose
and the passion then shows up so it's
not about doing something with passion
and then finding the cause it's finding
the cause
starting with why and then the passion
is what is what results
number two it's embarrassing this has to
be on the list courageous leadership
courageous leaders are the ones who are
willing to sacrifice the short term
in order to advance the long term
courageous leaders are the ones who are
willing to say no to the money
because it's coming from a dirty source
and rather say yes even though they know
they'll have to tighten the belt
in the short term because it's the right
thing to do
having a just cause if we don't actually
follow the just cause
if we don't actually make decisions
through the lens of the just cause is
just marketing
it's just marketing i'll give you my
favorite example right
the ioc the international olympic
committee they have a mission statement
what they believe is their just cause
which is to uh advance the world
make the world a better place through
sport but for the fact that they're all
corrupt
it's a great idea my point is is you
actually have to have leadership that
desperately profoundly believes in the
cause
and will make decisions to advance that
cause they would sooner sacrifice their
own personal interests
to take care of their people they would
never sacrifice their people
to protect their own interests it's
called leadership
it's called leadership we confuse rank
and leadership
rank has nothing to do with leadership i
know many people who sit
at the highest levels of organizations
who are not
leaders they have authority and we do as
they tell us because they have authority
over us
but we would not follow them and yet i
know many people who sit at lower ranks
who have no authority and yet they have
made a choice the choice to look after
the person to the left of them
and the choice to look after the person
to the right of them and we would trust
them
and follow them anywhere leadership is
the acceptance of the awesome
responsibility
to create an environment in which people
can work at their natural best
i think people misunderstand what the
word entrepreneur means
you know small business owners own small
businesses
and entrepreneurs solve problems and
there are many many entrepreneurs inside
corporations
yeah and not all small business owners
are entrepreneurs
i see um uh so an entrepreneur is
somebody who's constantly looking for a
better way to do something there there's
a there's a sort of a
mad scientist about them um
it's not simply you know understanding
structure and building business
um and and that's the way i was in the
corporate world
which you know depending on my boss was
either uh welcomed or or not
oh yeah no i used to get in trouble for
that's not how we do it around here
really did i break any rules they're
like no i'm like did i get it done
they're like yes
i'm like did i get it done better than
you expected they're like yes i'm like
so what exactly is the problem
how do you build trust faster within a
team says lee
how do you fall in love faster i mean
these are these are like you don't
it you know it takes as long as it takes
i hate to say that you know you know you
can go to the gym for nine hours but you
won't get into shape
but if you go to the gym every day for
20 minutes you will get into shape but
the problem is i don't know how long it
takes
it'll be a little quicker for some a
little slower for others and so there's
no app for trust there's no app for that
you know this is a human condition and
we have to do the things
that are right for human beings and you
won't build trust with everybody on the
team at the same pace
some will be quicker and some will be
slower how long does it take to make a
friend
you know i don't know i just know that
if you do the right thing
you will make a friend the problem with
passion you know people gave me the same
stupid advice
do what you love thank you thanks you
know
find your passion thank you like what am
i supposed to do with that advice
you know um and and what i learned is
that passion like profit is a result
when we commit ourselves to
some higher purpose on higher cause
passion is the result when we work hard
for something we don't believe in
it's called stress we work hard for
something we do believe in
it's called passion passion is not the
entry point it's at the exit point
so the question is not to find your
passion or find the thing you're
passionate about
the question is what do you believe the
question is what are your ideals what
are your values
and where are the places in which the
those people of those organizations
share your values share your beliefs
who is articulating a vision of a world
that you would like to live in
push yourself in those directions be
around those people you know align
yourself with those organizations
and what you will find is you show up
every day with passion i talk to so many
smart fantastic ambitious idealistic
hard-working kids
and they're right out of college they're
in their entry-level jobs and i'll ask
them
how's it going and they'll say i think
i'm gonna quit
and i'm like why they say to me i'm not
making an impact
i'm like you know you've been here eight
months right
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love
like it's a scavenger hunt like it's
something you look for
my millennial friends they've gone
through so many jobs they're either
getting fired
i mean it was mutual
or they're quitting because they're not
making an impact or they're not finding
the thing they're looking for they're
not feeling fulfilled as if it's a
scavenger hunt
love a job you
find joy from is not something you
discover
it's not like i found love here it is
i found a job i love that's not how it
works
both of those things require hard work
you are in love because you work
very hard every single day of your life
to stay
in love you find a job that brings you
ultimate joy because you work hard every
single day
to serve those around you and you
maintain that joy
it's not a discovery but the problem is
the sense of impatience
it's as if an entire generation is
standing at the foot of a mountain
they know exactly what they want they
can see the summit what they can't say
is the mountain
this large immovable object
that doesn't mean you have to do your
time that's not what i'm talking about
take a helicopter climb i don't care but
there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys
the problem is this entire generation
has an institutionalized sense of
impatience
and do they have the patience to go on
the journey to
maintain love to feel fulfilled or do
they just quit and on to the next
dump and on to the next ghost and on to
the next
in the 18th century
there was something that spread across
europe and eventually made its way to
america
puerto fever also known as the black
death of child bed basically what was
happening
is women were giving birth and
they would die within 48 hours after
giving birth
this black death of childbirth was the
ravage of europe and it got worse
and worse and worse over the course of
over a century
in some hospitals it was as high as 70
percent
of women who gave birth who would die as
a result of giving birth
but this was the renaissance this was
the time of
empirical data and science and we had
thrown away
things like tradition and mysticism
these were men of science these were
doctors
and these doctors and men of science
wanted to study and try and find the
reason
for this black death of child bed and so
they got to work
studying and they would study the
corpses
of the of the women who had died and in
the morning they would conduct autopsies
and then in the afternoon they would go
and deliver babies and finish their
rounds
and it wasn't until somewhere in the
mid-1800s
that dr oliver wendell holmes father of
supreme court justice
oliver wendell holmes realized that all
of these doctors were conducting
autopsies in the morning
weren't washing their hands before they
delivered babies in the afternoon
and he pointed it out and said guys
you're the problem and they ignored him
and called him crazy for 30 years
until finally somebody realized that if
they simply washed their hands
it would go away and that's exactly what
happened
when they started sterilizing their
instruments and washing their hands
the black death of child disappeared
my point is the lesson here is sometimes
you're the problem
we've seen this happen all too recently
with our new men of science and
empirical
studiers and these men of
finance who are smarter than the rest of
us
until the thing collapsed and they
blamed everything else except themselves
and my point is is take accountability
for your actions
you can take all the credit in the world
for the things that you do right
as long as you also take responsibility
for the things you do wrong it must
be a balanced equation you don't get it
one way and not the other
you get to take credit when you also
take accountability
i've learned that courage is not some
deep internal fortitude that you don't
dig down deep and find the courage you
know
that courage is external courage comes
from the relationships we have
with those around us um a partner in
business
a personal relationship our team right
that's why
we want to build good cultures because
our team believes in us which gives us
courage to do difficult things
um uh so a a
a um a trapeze artist a world famous
trapeze artist
would never try a brand new death
defying act for the very first time
without a net right now all that courage
they they're they're the world's
greatest true peace artist but for the
they need at something external before
they do something very dangerous yeah
and it's the same for the rest of us so
when we have someone who says
i believe in you i got your back
even if this doesn't work out i'm here
with you there's a lot of businesses
perhaps some of them are represented
here today
where actually doing the short term
thing for financial gain is smart
business it is smart
it is you know you do need because
you're working at a public company which
reports quarterly because
you need to keep shareholders on side
maybe you're worried about losing your
job if you don't hit a certain target in
march or april or may
isn't there a fundamental conflict
between the demands of some businesses
which are short-term interest based and
your vision of business so the argument
you're making is
is the argument you're making is
short-term based companies should make
short-term base decisions
which means they'll last for the short
term i'm not actually making i'm not
actually making an argument of any kind
i just wonder whether or not
actually the reality is maybe this is
why you make the point that
i'm raging against reality i think that
the systems we have in play
do not support uh capitalism i think we
have corrupted capitalism
which is capitalism at its best doesn't
follow the rules that we follow today
the concept of shareholders supremacy
was a theory proposed by a harvard
professor in the late 1970s
popularized in the 80s and 90s by basses
like jack welch
right the concept of using mass layoffs
to balance the books
mass redundancies because we missed our
numbers this is the mitt romney school
district right
did not exist as a standard way of doing
business prior to the 1980s it was a
it was popularized in the 80s and 90s
let's look at the 80s and 90s these were
boom years
of relative peace without the internet
right now that world does not exist we
no longer live in boom times
there is no longer relative peace and
the internet and the internet has
profoundly changed
the way business operates today in other
words what work then cannot work now
ge needed a 300 billion dollar bailout
in 2008 because that company was not
built to last
what i'm saying is the systems that we
consider normal ways of doing business
shareholder supremacy using mass
redundancies and other philosophies
in how we incentivize people how we hire
people et cetera et cetera
they are outdated and outmoded and they
are a race to zero
and the companies that continue to
embrace those philosophies big or small
are struggling with engagement they're
struggling with innovation
they go through people like nobody's
business and the executives keep getting
fired
or quitting right unceremoniously
um and by the way their shareholder
value
is unstable when you talk about what you
believe
people who believe what you believe
recommend you or want to introduce you
to people i see and so
um the more i talked about it the more
somebody would call me and say hey
there's someone i think you should meet
yeah and people
found me i don't know you know from
somebody else so you did not seek out i
want to do this
first no no so somebody somebody reached
out to me and said we're doing you know
they got my name
yeah and they said we've heard about you
we've heard your work uh we'd like to
invite you to do a tedx talk in puget
sound
in seattle yeah and i said okay
sounds amazing you know tedx was a um
there was a relatively new thing
back then and it was a big deal you know
it still had a lot of real sort of
sort of gravitas to it and so i was very
excited and of course
of course said yes to the opportunity
here's a thing that's always boggled my
mind right
why is it on balance on balance not
always but on balance why is it that
small companies tend to be more
innovative than big companies
right small companies that are
under-resourced can't
necessarily get the best and brightest
they're going to go out of business
any day and yet there's they come with
brilliant ideas and big companies full
of resources
full of amazing people by the little
companies
that come up with the good ideas that's
usually how big companies innovate they
buy the smaller ones
right um why is that why is it
that the most resource companies tend
not and i think it's a question of
reality and what i mean by that is small
companies
their vision is is
more distant than their grasp right
they have delusions of grandeur we're
going to change the world
change industries reinvent this reinvent
that we have no money and no people but
so what
the point is is the grasp is shorter
than the vision
and i think what happens is as companies
get bigger and bigger and bigger with
more and more resources what they start
to do is one of two things
either their their visions become well
within their grasp
and they don't readjust the vision or
they actually bring the vision back to
put within their grasps
right make things very achievable
difficult but achievable
for vision to truly be vision it should
feel unachievable when a small business
gets together and says here's our vision
everybody goes like this i
how are we going to do that in big
business we see here's a vision
everybody goes
all right yeah no got it we'll do a back
plan
and i i firmly believe that innovation
is born out of the struggle innovation
is born out of the resourcefulness
that you're forced to figure out because
literally
the vision is way beyond your grasp
regardless of how many resources you
have
it should always feel overwhelming and
impossible
take a group of people with tons of
resources to give them a vision they're
going to go
so how do you define success i think
successes
is is seeing those around you work to
their natural
best and creating momentum for a vision
towards a vision that will last
beyond yourself so a guy is driving a
bus
for 20 years got to retire he's on
madison avenue in new york
packed every day as people getting on
that bus and getting off
he has two kids wife lives in queens
he might call himself successful another
guy might be vice president of that
company
who calls himself unsuccessful so is
success what you make of it
so it's so this success is defined
it's success is a feeling it's not it's
not a series of check marks and goals
i think people define success as as
finish lines
you know well i ran a marathon i'm
successful the question is a why did you
run the marathon and what happens
after you've completed the marathon do
you just keep running marathons what
happens if you break your leg and you
can no longer run marathons you know we
set
a lot of people set financial goals i'm
successful when i make my first million
ah okay now i have to make my second
million it's success is a feeling
and and it's the feeling of contribution
so your bus driver in queens if he has
decided
that his job as a bus driver is to
ensure that
everyone who gets on his bus feels
better about themselves because they got
on his bus and not another bus
and so he greets them with a smile he
says good morning he says goodbye
that people will remember that that that
uh
that ride that they took with him versus
the this vice president of the company
who's made it about himself
and his financial goals he's the one
who's unhappy as opposed to seeing those
around him succeed
and those around him go home with a love
of their
their day you know because they come to
work in his company every day
so i i still believe success and and
good leadership are
about service to others what you'll find
is that that
um the better you are at communicating
your why
um people will want to work for you
uh regardless of the opportunity that
you afford them like they want to be a
part of it yeah
um we do a little thing which we've been
doing for years and years and years
called a give and take whenever there's
any kind of relationship whether it's a
an outside partnership or even somebody
who joins our team
we do something called a give and take
where we want somebody to be selfish and
selfless
within the relationship so not give and
get but give and take
so we'll ask them what is it that you
have to give to us
that you have that you you think that we
need right and they'll tell us and then
we'll say great
what is it that you selfishly want from
us and we want them to tell us what they
can get from us
and when those when those things match
you have a balanced relationship because
so for example i've had it with people
will you know they'll tell me what they
what they have to offer and that's
awesome because that's what i want and
then they'll say what they have
what they want to take and they go oh i
want to work with the smart people i'm
like
plenty of smart people what is it you
want to take from me they're like oh i
want to help build something
wonderful do that anywhere what do you
want to take selfishly from
me that you can get nowhere else and if
they can't answer the question i won't
engage in a relationship
and the reason is because in time the
relationship is unbalanced they're going
to be giving but they're not taking and
i don't even know how to give them what
they want then they'll complain they're
not making enough money or
because it's not balanced do you
consider yourself a writer i mean did
you were you already
writing lots of things and tell us about
your process not a writer never imagined
being a writer never
er fantasized about being a writer
um but um as i said other people who
believed what i believed i got very very
very good at talking about what i
believed and stopped
completely talking about what i did
people come to say what do you do and i
wouldn't
say what i did i would tell them what i
believed and
literally i started practicing the
things that i eventually wrote about
which is
i started with why and when you do that
it attracts people who believe what you
believe and so the way the book came
about is a friend of mine
who knew what i believed and that was
sharing my ideas with her said you have
to write this down and i shrugged
and she said i'll introduce you to an
agent and i shrugged and then i had an
agent
and somebody else said i wanna introduce
you to an editor friend i had and i
shrugged i said okay
and the editor talked to me said i wanna
introduce you to a publisher so my
meeting with the publisher
actually wasn't set up by my agent wow
and i ended up having
a 29-minute meeting with adrian zackheim
who's the god of business publishing
he's the original publisher from good to
great he came up with the title and
everything
wow and i'm here in this 29 minute
meeting with him
and uh three days later they offered me
a book deal
and i literally i i never presented
myself as anything that i was not and i
just would tell people what i believed
and i and what i imagined the world
could be based on this little idea
and people who believed who i believe
wanted to help and so he helped me by
offering me the opportunity to
to share my idea at a much broader scale
he absolutely took a bet on me
a trusting team is an environment in
which people feel
safe to raise their hand and say i made
a mistake
i don't feel qualified to do the job
you've asked me to do and i need more
training
i need help i'm struggling at home and
it's affecting my work
i'm scared without any fear
of humiliation or retribution or
punishment whatsoever
if you do not have trusting teams inside
your organization
what you do have is a group of people
who show up to work every single day
lying hiding and faking you're forcing
them to it's not their fault
you're creating an environment in which
people will not share mistakes for fear
that it puts them on some sort of short
list
or just getting in trouble they will not
admit that they don't feel qualified for
the jobs
that they have for fear of being
outcasts or again put on some sort of
short list of getting in trouble
which means eventually these things will
compound and eventually something
will break we've seen the results look
what happened with united airlines
we all saw the film of this poor paying
passenger being dragged off the plane
with a broken nose broken teeth and a
concussion right
and i feel for that crew i do not blame
the crew
because they work in a culture in which
they fear
making the right decision they actually
fear that they will get in they believe
they will get in trouble
before uh for making the right decision
they actually fear getting in trouble
more than doing the right thing this was
not an anomaly
this has been compounding over years i
had a personal experience on that
airline years prior
that was a red flag i was attempting to
board a plane
and um one of the passengers uh this
this
played out in front of me one of the
passengers attempted to board the plane
before their group number was called
which is all of you know here is a
felony
and that is exactly how the gate agent
treated him
step aside sir i haven't called your
group yet
please step aside and wait till i call
your group is how she talked to a paying
customer so i spoke up
i said why do you have to talk to us
that way why can't you talk to us like
we're human beings
and she looked me in the eye and said
sir if i don't follow the rules i could
get in trouble or lose my job
what she revealed to me is that she does
not feel safe in her own organization
and her leaders do not trust her to use
her own judgment
and they do not trust her to do the job
for what she's been trained to do
and guess who suffers customer and
company
the reason we love flying southwest
airlines is because not because they
have some magical formula to hire the
best people
it's because the people there feel safe
in their own organization
they're entrusted to use their own
judgment and do the jobs for which
they've been trained to do
if you have an excess of bureaucracy in
your organization
and i have worked in the university
system and i feel for the people
who abuse me when i go get my id
because they fear getting in trouble
more than using judgment
that is a cultural problem i do not
blame the person
human beings are social animals and we
respond to the environments we're in
and ultimately it is the leadership that
is responsible for setting the
environment
get the environment right you get
trusting teams get the environment wrong
you are forcing people to protect
themselves from you
if you work in an organization where it
is standard practice
for people to feel the need to send a
cya
email after every decision they make
cover your ass
that is a sign that they feel
that they have to take time and energy
out of their day away from doing their
jobs
in order to protect themselves from you
if you work in an organization where it
is standard practice
for people to feel the need that they
have to keep a folder of all the good
things they've ever done
just in case they need it it is a sign
that they feel that they have to take
time and energy away from advancing the
just cause
in order to protect themselves from the
organization
that's what you get if they feel safe
all of their energy goes to advancing
the just cause
i discovered that every single
organization on the planet
even our own careers always function on
the same three levels why we do what we
do
how we do it and what we do and it's
based on the biology of human decision
making
every single one of us knows what we do
it's the job we have
you know we know that or if the if it's
a company it's the products they sell
the services they offer
some can clearly articulate how they do
things the things that we think make us
different or special or stand out from
the crowd
but very few people or organizations can
clearly articulate
why they do what they do and by why i
don't mean to make money that's a result
by why i mean what is your purpose what
is your cause what is your belief
why did you get out of bed this morning
you know why does your company exist
and why should anyone care yeah and what
i learned is all the great leaders those
with the capacity to inspire us
everything from
steve jobs to nelson mandela regardless
of what they do
every single one of them starts with why
they always lead with their purpose
and like i said it's based on the
biology of human decision making so it's
it's not even my opinion
these people always complain that why
can't i ever get that
and these people complain i can never
get a job
you're going to be stressed no matter
what focus on the thing that you're
getting because that's the choice you
made right
much rather you focus the thing you you
you're you're pursuing rather the thing
you're missing
and so this idea of affirmative thinking
positive thinking
is essential for all people but i think
it's especially essential for artists
and there's a very very simple
biological reason
for it which is the human brain
cannot comprehend the negative it is
incapable
yes it's true i'll give you an example
[Music]
okay no no i'll give you an example you
don't have to believe me
i'll prove it i'll prove it okay the
human brain cannot comprehend the
negative you ready
don't think of an elephant
you can't you can't tell the human brain
not to do something
right and so what happens is we very
often reinforce
things when we put things in the
negative
right i can't get apart
i can't get apart i can't get apart
right or um um
i can't do this versus i'm gonna keep
doing this
i'm going to keep doing this i'm going
to keep doing this
right um and and it's it's such a huge
thing
to convert things into the affirmative
you're supposed to do with children as
well
we're supposed to say instead of saying
to children don't eat on the couch
we're supposed to say eat at the table
right we tell people what we want them
to do not what we don't want to do
pilots know this right it is well known
in the pilot community that when you
tell a pilot don't hit the obstacle
they'll hit the obstacle
because what they're doing is focusing
on the obstacle dopamine
is the feeling uh that you've found
something you're looking for or that you
accomplish something you set out to
accomplish
so you know that feeling you get when
you cross something off your to-do list
that's dopamine feels awesome you know
when you when you have a goal to hit and
you achieve that goal you're like
yes you feel like you've won something
right that's dopamine
the whole purpose of dopamine is to make
sure that we get stuff done
right um the historical reason for
dopamine
we would never eat if we only waited to
get until we got hungry because there's
no guarantee that we would find food
so dopamine exists to help us go looking
for food we get dopamine
when we eat which is one of the reasons
we like eating and so when you see
something that reminds you of something
that feels good we want to
do the behavior that helps us get that
feeling right so let's say you're out
there going for a walk and you see
an apple tree in the distance you get a
small hit of dopamine
and then what it does is it focuses us
on our goals and now we start walking
towards the apple tree
and as the apple tree starts to get a
little bigger
we feel like we're making progress you
get another little shot of dopamine
and another little shadow dopamine until
you get to the tree and you're like yes
okay this is why we're told you must
write down your goals
your goals must be tangible there's a
there's a biological reason for that we
we're
very very visually oriented animals you
have to be able to see
the goal for it to biologically stay
focused
right if you don't write down your goals
if you can't see your goals
it's very hard to get motivated to get
inspired
for example think about corporate
visions right a corporate vision is have
to be something we can
see right that's why it's called a
vision
you can see it right to be the biggest
most respected
to be the fastest growing are not
visions they're nothing
right what does that even look like
respected by whom your mother
yourself your friends your shareholders
who knows what's the metric
dunno it's amorphous doesn't motivate us
just like i can't tell you you will get
a bonus if you achieve
more you're going to ask me how much
more
i'm going to say more doesn't work
you need a tangible goal you need a
tangible goal right here's a great
vision
martin luther king i have a dream that
one day
little black children and little white
children will play on the playground
together and hold hands together
we can imagine that we can set our
sights on that and every time we achieve
a goal and achieve a metric
and achieve a milestone that makes us
feel like we're making progress to the
vision we can see we keep going and
going and going until we achieve
something remarkable
you have to be able to see it dopamine
like i said dopamine is the feeling you
get when you set out to find something
you're looking for as well
talked about the to-do list i came home
from
a trip just a couple days ago and i had
a bunch of errands to run and i wrote
down a little list of things i had to do
and off i went right and as i was
walking past
i think it was the dry cleaners i don't
remember i was walking past something
i remembered oh i have to do that and i
hadn't written it down on my i had
written down on my to-do list
so i went in and finished what i needed
to do and then when i came out
i then wrote it on my to-do list and
then crossed it out
because i wanted the dopamine feels good
dopamine comes with a warning dopamine
is
highly highly highly
addictive here are some other things
that release dopamine
alcohol nicotine gambling
your cell phone oh you think i'm joking
okay we've all been told that uh you
know
if you wake up in the morning and you
crave a drink
you might be an alcoholic well if you
wake up in the morning the first thing
you do is check your phone before you
even get out of bed
you might be an addict if you walk from
room to room in your own apartment
holding your telephone
you might be an addict when you're
driving in your car
and you get a text and your phone goes
beep we
we hate email true we love the beep the
buzz the ding oh
right you'll be there in 10 minutes and
yet you have to look at it
right now you might be an addict and
even if you read it and it says are you
free for dinner next thursday
and you have to reply immediately you
can't wait to ten minutes
you might be an addict and for all you
gen y's out there who like to think that
you're better at multitasking but you
grew up with the technology
then why do you keep crashing your cars
when you're texting
you're not you're not better at
multitasking you're better getting
distracted
in fact if you look at the statistics
add and adhd
have diagnosis of add and adhd have
risen
66 in the past 10 years okay add an adhd
is a frontal lobe disorder right are you
telling me
out of nowhere 66 of our youth has a
frontal lobe problem
where did that come from no it's a
misdiagnosis
right what what are the what are the
symptoms of a dopamine addiction to
technology
distractibility inability to uh to get
things done
easily easily distracted you know
shortness of attention it's all the same
thing so we misdiagnose things
it's this it's the addictive quality of
dopamine
we can also get addicted to performance
in our companies when all they do is
give us numbers to hit numbers to hit
numbers to hit and a bonus you get and a
bonus you get and a bonus you get
all they're doing is feeding us with
dopamine and we can't help ourselves all
we do is want more
more more it's no surprise that the
banks destroyed the economy
because one of the things we know about
dopamine addict is they will do anything
to get another hit sometimes at the
sacrifice of their own resources and
their relationships
ask any alcoholic gambling addict or or
drug addict
ask them how their relationships are
doing and if they've squandered any of
their resources
it's an addiction dopamine is dangerous
if it is unbalanced it is hugely helpful
when in a comfortable and balanced
system but when unbalanced
it's dangerous and it's destructive
there's a
brilliant leader by the name of david
marquez
who wrote a book called turn the ship
around and he had an experience as a
submarine captain
on the uss santa fe where he realized
that as much as he knew about
submarining you know he'd been a
submariner his whole career
that put on this new submarine he
learned the hard way that he actually
didn't know how the submarine worked he
he
he made an order that nobody knew how to
do it because there was that didn't
exist on that sub
and so he realized he had no choice but
to trust his people and he went through
this transformation as a leader
of telling everybody what to do to
allowing people to tell him what should
be done
and i've i've learned a lot from him and
i highly recommend his book
and and i i've i've really learned that
which is
you know at the top of the organization
as david says the people have all the
authority
the leaders have all the authority but
at the bottom they have all the context
right and so you can't just push all the
context up you have to push the
authority down
um and so the responsibility of
leadership is to train people
make sure that they have the skill set
help build their confidence that that
they have the confidence to do what
needs to be done yeah they have to have
competence and confidence
right and that's that's your job that's
the only job of the leader makes it's
like
like a parent make sure they have
competence and confidence you know make
sure your kids get schooling and make
sure that they believe in themselves
and then leave them you know and so i've
i've done the same thing instead of sort
of showing people how i would do it
i want them to learn how it's done you
know
and feel good about themselves and then
just however they do it is how they do
it
yeah you know um and the result is
remarkable
people feel better about coming to work
they feel like they have something to
contribute they feel more valuable
as opposed to just being told this is
how i would do it or i'm going to do it
this way
or do it my way um so yeah um
completely changing my understanding of
my job
as um more like a parent than a
manager has had remarkable impact
so i i went to this event and just by
sheer coincidence at the dinner i'm
sitting next to
dawn and sam goldwurm who run this
company called 1229 and that's exactly
what they do
dawn is a master nose who used to work
for cody the perfume company so you
produce all the famous perfumes that we
all know
and they went off to start their own
company where they design
custom sense for brands but the way to
think about this is
beyond sort of verbena and patchouli the
way dawn explained it to me is
um there are seven notes on the musical
scale
and you can play chopsticks or you can
play a beethoven symphony it's the same
seven notes it's what you do with it and
she does the same thing
with smell which is you can have simple
smells or you can have highly complex
ornate orchestras uh
symphonies rather and so they sat down
with me and took me through
a fantastic process and they produced
the smell
of optimism and it's the most beautiful
thing
and the idea was born out of the fact
that i'm sitting next to this event
and i turned them and said have you ever
sent it a book has that ever been done
before
and they said no it's never been done i
said well we shouldn't really do that
and so of course my publisher was not
excited to hear about that but
but it's the first time that i know that
a book has ever been centered in this
way
so it is a scented book the smell of
optimism
uh is what you start with and it sets
you on your journey to enjoy the rest of
the book
i'll ask you a very simple question why
does your organization
exist we don't need you
clearly there's plenty of competition
clearly people have plenty of choices
even the things that you may specialize
in there are others that do
a reasonably good job they might even be
better than you in some
areas so why do you exist
providing education is table stakes
everybody here does that you can't rely
on that
that's why the industry exists not why
your organization exists
that's like when i talk to healthcare
companies and say why does your
organization exist and they say to help
people be more healthy
like no kidding thank you but i know
that the culture of one organization
is different than the culture of another
organization there are cultural norms
that wrap around the sense of purpose
cause or belief great organizations
understand their just cause a cause
so just that people would be willing to
sacrifice to see the advancement of that
cause
sacrifice comes in many forms it might
mean
working longer hours giving you my best
ideas
turning down a better job that offers me
more money to stay here
because i believe in what you're doing
and i want to see that advanced
one of my favorite examples of a just
cause is the declaration of independence
our founding fathers declared literally
wrote down
they declared why we needed our own
country
all men are created equal endowed with
these unalienable rights amongst which
include life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
they were never against britain the
whole point is not to be against
something but to stand for something
britain was simply standing in the way
of them advancing their cause and though
they
won independence there are always finite
games within the infinite game
though they won independence that didn't
mean that they had now provided all men
are equal now the real heavy lifting
began
now let's be crystal clear when they
said all men are equal what they meant
was white protestant men let's be
crystal clear
but even early on during the
revolutionary war
george washington understood how
limiting that was and he realized that
they had to have a broader definition
so he included catholics
he banned any organizing against
catholics and his armies and he would
regularly attend
mass to send the right message
some time later we abolished slavery
and the 14th amendment some time later
we had women's suffrage sometime later
we had civil rights act sometime later
we implement gay rights and you can see
that we are striving
to provide this thing called all men are
equal people are equal and though we
will never actually get there we will
die
trying and the obstacles may always be
different and what a just cause is
it is a vision of the future that does
not yet exist and you will commit
all of your energies to advance that
vision of the world that you have
and the people you want to attract both
those who work there
those who teach there and both those who
come to learn there
believe in your vision of the future so
much so
that they may turn down a better offer
from someone else
because they want to be around people
who are committed to building this world
that does not yet exist and every single
single one of these organizations that
you run and represent
can have different visions or
overlapping visions of the world but you
must be clear what your just cause
is what you stand for otherwise the only
thing i have to judge you on
is superficial things it's like dating
right it's like dating if if somebody
tells me what they stand for
who they are they're talking about their
character
and those are the people we want to
spend the rest of our lives with
if we do not have any sense of who they
are
what they stand for what their purpose
what their cause what their beliefs are
what their
values are the only thing we have to
judge them on is how much money they
make and how good looking they are
the word entrepreneur is bandied about
too loosely
that not everyone who owns a small
business is an entrepreneur there are
small business owners
and they're entrepreneurs what's an
entrepreneur and you can find
entrepreneurs in big companies
it doesn't mean that they're small
business owners right i think
entrepreneurs are problem solvers
i think rather than risk takers yeah i
think fundamentally there are plenty of
risk takers i think who
are entrepreneurs there's a risk taker
if you're a small business owner right
you went out to start the business but
they're not the same i don't think
um and entrepreneurs are those ones who
they're constantly looking to solve
problems and that's where i think they
perceive opportunity or the mischief
that you describe
i don't think it's i don't think
inherently it's a sense of mischief
they're not trying to stir the pot for
the sake of stirring the pot
i think that they see something and
they're like we can make that better or
we can fill
that hole and that's very much the way
the famous entrepreneurs
the elon musk and the richard bransons
operate they see gaps
they see things that don't work as their
jobs as did jobs they see things that
could be better
i had the marketing business lost my
passion for what i was doing
that crisis um was the spark that
helped me find this thing called the y
and then define the golden circle
and um i would fell in love with this
idea
and would literally go to my friend's
apartments and give talks to their
friends
about this thing called the y and i
would help people find their why for 100
bucks on the side that's how it began
okay and people just kept kept asking me
to speak and i kept saying yes so i was
actually giving the talk for about three
years
before any book or ted talk and that's
when
i abandoned my marketing business
because i realized when i realized i
could make a living doing this that
people
will pay me to speak and will also
invite me to come and
consult i guess but as it started to
gain popularity then the question was
what do i want to do and i i made the
conscious decision not to build a
consultancy
um because i didn't want for me
spreading the message was much more
important so i sort of took on the
the the identity of sort of a modern day
preacher i had a purpose i had a cause i
had a calling
i had a something i believed in that i
was going to preach i was going to share
it i was going to stand on my bully
pulpit
and i was going to look for followers to
help me spread this spread this gospel i
mean that's really the the angle i took
and that's what we've done and the
reason the message has spread is because
that's what we
decided we would do so with steve jobs
playing the finite game because he was
crushing the competition
or was he playing the infinite game
because he just did his own thing
so jobs had a very clear vision
and it was to give the individual the
power to stand up to big brother
he was at his heart a rebel he grew up
in
northern california during the vietnam
war
which was the where the beginning of the
anti-establishment revolution sort of
started
yeah and that was his childhood um and
so he really
he really stood for the individual
standing up to
to to the man and he had a big spiritual
side he was a buddhist at times
yeah and if you look at the decisions he
made he made decisions like this
he ran decisions through his vision
before he got to the interests
right so there's a very famous story
of when he went to xerox park do you
know this one
so jobs they just come up the success of
the apple one and the apple ii
it's already a big company he's already
well known it's a
it's he's already the darling of
business um
and uh their next big push is going to
be into a technology they called the
lisa
that was their next computer that they
were going to launch
and just as executives do they visit
each other's companies
and jobs and a few of his colleagues
went to visit xerox park
and xerox showed them a new technology
that they had invented
called the graphic user interface right
now remember jobs believed in the
individual standing up to big brother
so the reason they made their computers
beautiful was not arbitrary
it's because if you had them if they
were pretty looking you'd put them in
the living room
if they're ugly you put them in the
basement and you're more likely to use
something that's in the living room than
if it's in the basement
right the reason you make them simple is
because more people can
then use them and so when he saw this
thing called the graphic user interface
he thought this is a better technology
it's a leapfrog
to make it easier for more individuals
to access the power of the personal
computer
than what we have in the lisa so that's
an infinite game because he's thinking
about what's right for the long term
rather than what his competition and as
they left
dirk park job says we have to invest in
this and his
colleagues said we're you're crazy we've
invested millions of dollars
millions of man hours already in the
lisa if we
do this if we invest in this we're going
to blow up our own company
to which jobs replied better we should
blow it up than someone else
that decision became the mac the
macintosh that decision was the
macintosh
of which remember windows is an
interface designed to copy the macintosh
in other words he completely changed the
way computers work to the point where
now any individual
can easily use a computer and he he
always made decisions that way
he made decisions always empowering the
individual so he was asked
a question about the movie industry
cinemas and the decline of cinemas and
he replied that
the the cinemas were making the same
mistake the movie industry was making
the same mistake that the music industry
made
which is the music industry falsely
believed that their customer
was tower records and virgin megastore
and not the person who actually spent
money on buying the album
he says you've confused your customer
with you with your distribution channel
i was boarding a flight and the scene
played out in front of me
where one of the passengers attempted to
board the plane before
their group number was called um and the
gate agent
uh literally berated him sir step aside
i haven't called your group
please step aside and wait till i call
your group so i spoke up and said
why do you have to talk to us that way
why can't you talk to us like we're
human beings
and she looked me in the eye and said if
i don't follow the rules i could get in
trouble or lose my job
all she revealed to me is that she
doesn't feel safe in her own company
and her leaders do not trust her to do
the job for which he's been trained to
do
and guess who suffers us and the company
the reason we love flying southwest
airlines
is because the company trusts them to do
the job they've been trained to do
and they use discretion we don't trust
people to follow the rules we trust
people to know
when to break them and the problem is in
a fear-based society
people fear for their own jobs more than
common sense
that was a perfectly a perfect scenario
of what happens
when somebody in the company is too
afraid to break
the rule break the policy use discretion
find another way
you know so almost predictable that
something will happen something will
break at some point
no i consider myself a student in all
these things like i don't even consider
myself an expert in leadership or any of
the stuff that i even write about right
i couldn't consider myself a student and
though my learning may be more advanced
than some people
i show up every single day to see what i
can learn
isn't that a trait of a great leader is
that they just they never say
finished done i'm a great leader they're
constantly learning well the best
leaders that i've ever met
um don't consider themselves experts
they do they are all sort of
they all believe there's room to grow
and no matter how senior or how advanced
they they have this sort of uh
um you know childlike curiosity they
don't always agree with everything but
they wanna
they wanna they wanna hear people's
ideas yeah and they lean in
and they tend to ask a lot of questions
nelson mandela
is a particularly special case study
in the leadership world because he is
universally regarded
as a great leader you can take other
personalities and depending on the
nation you go to we have different
opinions about other personalities but
nelson mandela
across the world is universally regarded
as a great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief
and he was asked one day how did you
learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father
to tribal meetings and he remembers two
things
when his father would meet with other
elders one
they would always sit in a circle
and two his father was always
the last to speak you will be told your
whole life that you need to learn to
listen
i would say that you need to learn to be
the last to speak
i see it in boardrooms every day of the
week even people who consider themselves
good leaders who may actually be decent
leaders
will walk into a room and say here's the
problem here's what i think but i'm
interested in your opinion let's go
around the room
it's too late the skill to hold your
opinions to yourself until everyone has
spoken
does two things one it gives everybody
else the feeling
that they have been heard it gives
everyone else the ability to
feel that they have contributed and two
you get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion
the skill is really to keep your
opinions to yourself
if you agree with somebody don't nod yes
if you disagree with somebody don't not
know
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is
ask questions so that you can understand
what they mean
and why they have the opinion that they
have you must understand
from where they are speaking why they
have the opinion they have
not just what they are saying and at the
end
you will get your turn it sounds
easy it's not practice being the last to
speak
that's what nelson mandela did every
decision we make in our lives as
individuals
or as organizations is a piece of
communication
it's our way of saying something about
who we are and what we believe
this is why authenticity matters this is
why you have to say
and do the things you actually believe
because the things you say and do are
symbols
of who you are and we look for those
symbols so we can find people who
believe what we believe
our very survival depends on it so if
you're putting out false symbols
you will attract people to those symbols
but you won't be able to form
trust with them this is what tiger woods
did to us
he lied he lied he told us what
he thought we wanted to hear and it was
great
and we were drawn to it and all of us
who kind of like that idea of the
sort of the good guy we're drawn to it
until we found out it was a lie
he could have been the bad boy of golf
he could have had all the same
endorsements and had a fantastic career
and still been hailed as one of the
great
athletes of our day but he didn't he
chose to lie
good luck forming trust again tiger we
don't believe you
we don't trust you the goal of putting
something out there
if you say what you believe and you do
what you believe you will attract people
who believe
what you believe if you go to one of
your friends and you say to one of your
friends
how would you like me to dress so that
you'll like me better
how would you want me to address you how
do you want me to speak
so that you'll like me more right
your friends are going to look at you
and be like what are you talking about
come on come on come on what should i
wear so that you'll find me more
appealing
and how would you like me to speak to
you so that you'll like me more
and your friends are going to tell you
just be yourself
that's why i like you i don't just be
yourself now think about what we do in
industry
what do we do we do market research and
we go out and we ask the customers
what kind of things the way we what
style should we speak to you how should
we decorate ourselves what kind of
things are you drawn to so that we can
do those things so you'll like us more
it's just as ridiculous
it's just as ridiculous organizations
should say and do the things they
actually believe
and they will attract people who believe
what they believe or they can choose to
lie
and at the slightest hint that they
might be lying
cynicism sets in and people start saying
i'm not sure i can trust
these guys because there's not a lot of
consistency in all the things they say
and do
which means they can't have a very
strong belief set or they're lying to me
and we call them inauthentic the entire
process of asking other people who we
should be
is inauthentic that's hilarious to me
all these positioning studies we do
are inherent we're going to do a study
to find out from people so we can be
more authentic
that's hilarious
say and do what you actually believe and
the symbols you put out there
the things you say and the things you do
those red hats are ways that people can
find you
what you have the ability to do as
designers
is create those symbols and allow people
to
use those things to say something about
who they are
work for companies work for clients work
for people
who you believe what they believe
show up and feel a part of something
bigger than yourself
and your part is to put what they
believe into
pictures and words and symbols and
graphics so that other people can use
those things to say something about who
they are
people put harley davidson logos on
their body to say something about who
they are
corporate logo ain't no proctor and
gambles tattooed on anybody's arm
because harley means something they
stand for something
people put that tattoo on there not to
tell you that they own a motorcycle
they put that tattoo there to tell you
something about themselves
you ever see anybody with a with a mac
laptop with a sticker over that
beautiful shining apple
ain't never going to happen then how
will you know who i
am do you ever see anybody with a pc
break out the windex to clean out their
computer mac people
have you ever seen a dirty mac doesn't
exist
does not exist why because it's who i am
these are symbols we use the companies
that are crystal clear in what they
believe and they're disciplined in how
they do it they're consistent what they
do and everything they say
and everything they do serves as a
symbol of the set of values and beliefs
we
use those symbols to say something about
who we are
we surround ourselves with the people
and the products and the brands that say
something about who
we are and when we can find the people
who believe what we believe
we're weirdly drawn to them because our
very survival
depends on it we need it
and so the more you can give of yourself
the more you can give of what you
believe the more you can
discipline with discipline say and do
the things you actually believe strange
things start to happen
what are your thoughts and what's your
approach on finding
and building upon passions passion is
not
an actionable word it's correct you know
that those who do the things that
they're passionate about
do better but it's not helpful advice um
and so the question is where does
passion come from passion
is a result passion is an energy passion
is the feeling you have when you're
engaged in something
that you love passion is the feeling you
have
that you would probably do this for free
you know and you can't believe somebody
pays you to do it you know
and i think we mistake that passion is
something we do in our private lives but
it shouldn't be done
you know in our careers for example and
i'm a firm believer that you are who you
are
and anybody who says i'm different at
home than i am at work and one of those
two places you're lying
and the goal is to make everything you
do in
home and at work something that you have
excitement to do
so how do you find the things that
you're excited to do well it's actually
easier than you think what are the
things that you
love to do what are the things that you
would do for free
you know how can you recreate that
feeling and and be paid for it so
what are the things that i do on the
weekend right i love um
i'm very involved in the art world i
love to go to museums and galleries but
i love to go see
dance and performances because i want to
see how others are
interpreting the world so that inspires
me new ideas new thoughts new ways of
looking at the world
are things that interest me privately
and i seek it out and pay money for it
right so does that mean i have to have a
career in the arts
no it means i have to have a career
where new ideas are explored
where people are experimenting and
trying things out and i have to explore
new ideas and try things out and i'm
just as excited to go to work every day
as i am to
you know go do something on a saturday
night um and so the idea of finding your
passion is
ironically simple because you should be
doing stuff that you enjoy
sometimes what is the stuff that you
enjoy and then what is the stuff that
you
love who are the people that you love
and what are those what they all have in
common
society and folks like me put an unfair
pressure on people to
have a vision yeah right and i think
that's true we're not all steve jobs and
we don't all have big
world changing visions to your point i
do believe however
you can find a vision right in other
words it doesn't have to be yours
it can be someone else's we found
martin luther king we found mahatma
gandhi we found steve jobs we found
richard branson whoever
elon musk the visionaries and people go
i i love his vision
so organize your business around that
right you don't have to have a vision
but i do believe you have to find
one people find it in religion you know
you
follow whatever you follow right you you
become a follower of so you can say i
belie and you can say theirs is yours i
believe
in that and we're organizing our our
company around
helping to build that world yeah so i
don't believe you have to have one i do
believe you have to find one
yeah right and it doesn't have to always
operate at a macro level it absolutely
can operate at a micro level
right it can be the way you raise your
family the way you treat your friends i
think the difference between an
entrepreneur who
who cannot achieve scale which is
different from success you can make a
ton of money but that's not scale it's
just money right versus being able to
cross that little chasm and find that
tipping point where it can really gain
scale
is the ability to let go um you know i'd
been chief cook and bottle washer i had
done
every job and so when i started needing
help because i could no longer do every
job i didn't have the time or the energy
i wanted to tell everybody how i used to
do it and
have them do it that way that's that's
that's about
like assigning tasks that's not
assigning responsibility that's not
letting go
and it was a slow uncomfortable process
it's not like tomorrow morning i'm just
gonna let go you know it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't work that way it's a
very uncomfortable process i assume you
you use the analogy of
this is your baby i assume it's
something like when your kids grow up
and leave the house or when they
become old enough to drive and they gain
some independence like we'd like to tell
them
what to do what to eat when to go to bed
when to have a shower
but you kind of lose that and some
parents struggle with that
and it creates tension in the
relationship with their kids and some
parents slowly embrace that their kids
are adults and
and it's the same kind of transition
where you people come on and you realize
that they care
and that they're smart and that they're
good at what they do and that
they want to learn and so they want to
do things they've never done before also
they don't have to be experts in
everything and you
let go a little bit they do an amazing
job and you let go and amazing a little
bit
and then they you let go a little bit
and they screw it all up
and you say okay try again
and the more they feel that you care
about their success
the more i started to feel um that i
cared about
the success of those around me it became
very easy for me
to simply say just take care of this and
whatever happens is fine in every
decision you make i love
people would come up to me and say how
are you going to do another ted talk as
successful as the first one and the
answer was
i'm not that was an accident i won the
lottery
like i won the lottery and i can't plan
to win the lottery again like that's not
how it works
and the success of start with why again
like
i can't plan that like there's nothing
you can't plan for something that was an
accident
so i had actually completely divorced
myself of
any notion that i had to produce
something that was better or more
successful
than the first work and so when i set
out to write leaders eat last
the only goal was to share every lesson
that i'd been learning on the topic of
trust and cooperation
and do the best job i can of
communicating
those ideas with literally no concern or
thought whether it would be
more successful than the first one i
didn't mind i didn't care
um and uh i feel that way about all my
work which is
you know the y has sort of gone off and
done its own thing
and uh and it's like my kid leaving the
house i'm like just so proud of it
bad teams work in the same place good
teams work together i love that
it says so much you know the word team
is so bandied about so easily like this
is my team it's like no you just happen
to work in the same office
you know you're assigned to the same
product but do you love each other do
you trust each other do you care about
each other will you sacrifice for each
other are you
do you take real joy in seeing your
friends your colleagues your teammates
have success or are you bitter and angry
that they got promoted before you
you know does it do you mind that you
sometimes don't get the credit
you know that's a real team
there's real love there the rest i think
are just colleagues
let me tell you a story so a friend of
mine and i
we went for a run in central park the
road runners organization
on the weekends they host races and it's
very common at the end of the race
they'll have a sponsor who will give
away
something apples or bagels or something
and on this particular day when we got
to the end of the run
there were some free bagels and they had
picnic tables set up and on one side was
a group of volunteers
on the table were boxes of bagels and on
the other side was a long
line of runners waiting to get their
free bagel
so i said to my friend let's let's get a
bagel and he looked at me and said
uh the line's too long and i said
free bagel and he said i don't want to
wait
in line and i was like free bagel
and he says nah let's it's too long and
that's when i realized that there's two
ways to see the world
some people see the thing that they want
and some people see the thing
that prevents them from getting the
thing that they want
i could only see the bagels he could
only see the line
and so i walked up to the line
i leaned in between two people
put my hand in the box and pulled out
two bagels
and no one got mad at me because the
rule is
you can go after whatever you want you
just cannot deny
anyone else to go after whatever they
want
now i had to sacrifice choice i didn't
get to choose which bagel i got i got
whatever i pulled out
but i didn't have to wait in line so the
point is
you don't have to wait in line you don't
have to do it the way everybody else has
done it
you can do it your way you can break the
rules
you just can't get in the way of
somebody else getting what they want
that's rule number one why are you an
optimist why do you choose to see the
world that way
yeah i mean i don't know if optimists
choose to see that way i think well i
guess you can choose to be an optimist
it
is a point of view that you can take
right you can look for everything bad in
the world and think the world is
crashing and it'll never get better or
you can choose to see the good in people
and choose to see
the good in the world and then that's
the direction that that will follow
um and um you know i i
i tend to believe that there's no
finality in anything
you know it's not like uh you know
you're even though we
our lives are finite life is infinite
you know life goes on and
and for me the goal is not to produce
something that has an end point but to
produce something
that has momentum that can live on
beyond me and so i choose an optimistic
path
i mean i'm only successful because of
other people i mean in the early days
when i just started my business i was
pretty much convinced it was me
and everyone else was helping me out you
know but i can tell you with hindsight
that
the reason my business took a nosedive
because my
whole trajectory changed the first three
years of my business were
fun and exciting and we sort of beat the
statistic that
you know the overwhelming number was
supposed to go to business and i didn't
um and my fourth year was very difficult
uh my fourth year was very different and
that's where you know
when you're running on force of
personality where you your chief cook
and bottle washer you're making every
sales call you're making
you're doing the the product you're
making every you're offering the service
you're doing everything
um at some point you reach a level where
especially if you survive for a few
years that you now have to ask other
people for help so you have to hire
people
right and the stress of letting go when
or trying to do everything which is
demoralizing for people who you bring on
and then needing structure you know what
is the actual structure of the business
it's not just
you doing everything and that's where i
failed i was terrible at structure i
continue to be terrible at structure
and and really became very very
difficult for me to grow my business
became very very stressful
and um i really hit a dark patch um
and that's when i learned the most
valuable lesson i think of my career
which is i don't have to know all the
answers
and when i don't i don't have to pretend
that i do
and a willingness to admit that i needed
help
that i didn't know i knew this but i
didn't know that
allowed me to seek help and accept it
when it was offered
and i realized i'm we're all surrounded
by people who are
plenty willing to help us but because so
many of us spend so much of our time
lying hiding and faking people don't
offer us their help because they just
don't think we need it
yeah because we've presented ourselves
in this picture that we're good to go
and so we leave ourselves by ourselves
it's our own fault and so when i was
able to stop lying hiding and faking
and was able to say really good at this
really bad at that
and it wasn't a depressing thing it was
just like an admission
people came up all over ago oh my i
could totally help you with that
and that's when my real trajectory took
off was when i
i realized that um it's it's a team
sport
and i'm i have to be really good at the
thing that i'm good at
and i have to be willing to help those
succeed at what they're good at
and allow others to help me succeed as
well
at what i'm good at and so it's that
wonderful wonderful sort of relationship
that we all have each other where we
commit ourselves to seeing each other
succeed
that is the reason i find myself where i
am today performing under pressure
whether it's me or anybody else is the
same you know i have the same pressures
as anyone else there's time there's
performance there's financial i mean
there are
you know there's deadlines my pressures
are not unique
um the situations may be different or
you know but but
everybody has the same kinds of
pressures um
but what i found or what i find
fascinating is the interpretation of the
stimuli
if let me let me explain so i was
watching the olympics this last summer
olympics
and i was amazed at how bad the
questions were that the reporters would
ask
all the athletes and almost always they
asked the same question
whether they were about to compete or
after they competed
were you nervous right and
to a t all the athletes went no
right and what i realized is it's not
that they're not nervous it's their
interpretation of what's happening in
their bodies i mean
what happens when you're nervous right
your heart rate starts to go
you're you know you sort of get a little
tense you get a little sweaty right you
have expectation of what's coming and we
interpreted that as i'm nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing it's the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
olympic quality athletes
have learned to interpret the stimuli
that the rest of us would say as
nervous as excited they all say the same
thing no i'm not nervous
i'm excited and so i've actually
practiced it
just to tell myself when i start to get
nervous that this is excitement
yeah you know and so where when you i
used to speak in front of a large
audience and somebody would say how do
you feel i should say
a little nervous now when somebody says
how do you feel i'm like
pretty excited actually and it it came
from just sort of telling myself
no no this is excitement and it becomes
a little bit automatic later on
um but it's kind of a remarkable thing
to deal with pressure by interpreting
what your body is experiencing
as excitement rather than nerves and
it's really kind of effective it makes
you want to rush forward rather than
pull back and yet it's the same
experience
i spoke at an education summit for
microsoft i also spoke at an education
summit for
apple at the education for mike at the
education summit for microsoft
i would say that 70 of the executives
spent about 70 percent
of their presentations talking about how
to beat
apple at the apple education summit
a hundred percent of the executives
spent a hundred percent of their
presentations talking about how to help
teachers teach and how to help students
learn
one is playing this way and one is
playing that way
one is playing finite and the other one
is playing infinite gets which one gets
frustrated
so at the end of my talk at microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
zune
when it was a thing
and let me tell you this thing was
spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology i'd ever used the user
interface
was incredible the design was
spectacular
i absolutely loved it it was easy to use
and it was
bright and gorgeous and fanta it didn't
work on itunes which is a different
problem
so i couldn't use it but but it was
amazing
and elegant my god it was elegant so i'm
sitting in the back of a taxi with a
very senior apple executive sort of
employee number 12 kind of guy
and you know i like to stir pots so i
turned him i said you know
microsoft gave me their new zoom
and it is so much better than your ipod
touch
and he turned to me and he said i have
no doubt
conversation over
because the infinite player understands
sometimes your head and sometimes you're
behind
sometimes your product is better and
sometimes it's worse the goal isn't to
be the best
every day the goal isn't to out to outdo
your competition
every day that's a finite construction
if i had said to microsoft i've got the
new ipod touch and it's so much better
than your zoom
they would have said can we see it what
does it do react react react react
finite players play to be bet to beat
the people around them
infinite players play to be better than
themselves
to wake up every single day and say how
can we make our company a better version
of itself today
than it was yesterday how can we create
a product
this week that's better than the product
we created last week we
also have to play the infinite game it's
not about being ranked number one
it's not about having more followers on
twitter than your friends
it's not about outdoing anyone it's
about how to outdo
yourself it's not about selling more
books or getting more ted views
than somebody else it's about how to
make sure that the work that you're
producing
is better than the work you produced
before
you are your competition and that is
what ensures you stay in the game the
longest
and that is what ensures you find joy
because the joy comes not from
comparison
but from advancement when are you at
your best
i'm at my best when i'm around people
who believe what i believe
i know it seems silly but um
i try very very hard to sort of stack
the deck you know to put myself in a
position of strength
um so for example you know somebody
asked me just yesterday have you ever
had sort of a bad
you know engagement i was thinking
myself i'm like not really but it's not
because i'm
some sort of sort of genius
understanding anything like that
it's because i stack the deck it's
because i want to be there i want to be
around people who want me there
in other words if i'm somebody's tenth
choice and like you know i'll probably
turn it down
um whereas if i'm their first choice
they really want me there and so i'm i'm
more likely to have a good engagement
they're supportive of me i'm supportive
of them
and so um yeah i'm at my best when i
when i stack the deck when i choose to
be in an environment
where where my strengths are are there
people are always talking about visions
and missions and all of this stuff
um and um when people ask me like what
example should i look to
like what company should i'm like here's
an organization
with a vision a cause it was founded
with a cause
um it's an entrepreneurial venture it's
america is an experiment it's an
entrepreneurial venture
where a bunch of people got together and
decided we needed to
start our own country um um
because there were certain obstacles
that were getting in the way of a vision
that we had of a better kind of country
but a kind of company right
um and they stated it right at the
beginning all men are created equal
endowed with these unalienable rights
and much amongst which include life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
and it's not a uh it's not just um a
competitive statement
like to be the best to be the most
respected that's not what it was
and i'm amazed how many companies start
their visions or missions
with those that terribly egocentric
language
it was an ideal and the amazing thing is
is we've been good at it and bad at it
in our history
but it's endured for 240 plus years
because we fundamentally believe that we
are at our best when we're pursuing that
but it
isn't ideal we will never actually
achieve all people
are equal but we will die trying and
that's the point
and it's the same for a company which is
true vision inside a company
is something that has nothing to do with
your product it is an ideal
to which you will attempt to build and
advance that ideal through your company
with your product
you'll never achieve the ideal but
you'll die trying and this is what gives
our work meaning this is what it gives
our lives purpose
right the difference between vision and
a goal is the finish line
a goal is 26.2 miles you can simply
count the metrics
and know when you've completed your goal
is a vision
is having a crystal clear sense of what
the finish line looks like but no idea
of how far away it is
wow and it's and the reality is you'll
spend your entire
life never actually crossing the finish
line but the joy that every marathon you
complete you feel like you're getting
closer
every milestone that you accomplish
makes you feel like you're getting
closer and closer to the ideal
and this is what gives our life and our
work meaning success is an elusive thing
right
what is it and i think it's very
interesting that if most people can't
define success well it means you made x
amount of dollars
or but if you make x amount of dollars
but you spend more
are you successful or well it means you
come home happy every day
okay how do you know when you're happy
you know uh
so i think success is a funny thing
which is we all seem to pursue it
but we don't know how to measure it or
actually how to define it
so how do you pursue something that you
can't measure fascinating
so when people say to me how do you
measure success the question we all have
to ask ourselves am i successful
i don't know i mean i had a good year
last year uh
and what does that mean does that mean i
made a lot of money does that mean i was
really happy oh i'll let you decide
right
right maybe neither maybe both
i had a good year last year but am i
successful and the answer is no
i don't feel i am because i'm trying to
build a world that doesn't exist yet
i'm trying to build a world in which 90
of people go home at the end of the day
feeling fulfilled by the work that they
do
so i definitely took a step a big step
forward towards that goal but i'm still
so far away
so somebody said to me then how do you
know if you're successful and the answer
is
if it can go by itself and so what is
more interesting to me
as a measurement of success is not the
the the markers per se
it's not the the financial goal or the
the size of the house that you want to
buy those are nice things go for it
those are
but those are not measurements of
success those are just nice things to
collect along the way
right um for me it's momentum i want to
measure momentum which is
you know when when something is moving
and you start to see it lose momentum
you're like oh
give it a push because if you don't give
it push it's going to stop and an object
in stasis is much harder to get going it
requires a lot more energy
to get something started than it does to
keep it going right and so
if you don't let it stop and you can
keep it going it's this you know it
still might slow down down there but you
can get it going again much easier
and for me the opportunity is to get the
ball rolling faster and faster and
faster and faster and faster and bigger
and bigger and bigger it's like a
snowball
and my responsibility is because it's
not rolling downhill yet it's not on
automatic yet
i need to still keep it going to find
that critical mass where it can go
and at the point it can go by itself
without me then i will find something
else to do
and that may not happen in my lifetime i
think we must all stop measuring
promotions salaries and these things but
rather measure the momentum of your
career
does my career have momentum can i see
it moving in the right direction can i
see it gathering
moss you know uh can i see that it's
easy becoming easier for me
to keep the momentum it's becoming
easier for me to grow the size of this
thing it's it's requiring less effort
that's the thing we need to measure
that's the thing that we need to be
cognizant of which is the momentum of
our careers not just
the markers that we think define our
success i did a little experiment
with um um with a homeless person
not like on them it's not like
electrodes
with them voluntarily um helped me
um because the whole idea of giving
right
you've all walked down the street and
you've all seen someone begging
and you either have or haven't thrown a
few pennies in their cup
when you do you feel good
you bought that feeling that is a
legitimate
commercial transaction you know
commercial transactions are defined as
the exchange of consideration
there was an exchange of consideration
here you gave money
you got the feeling of goodwill you paid
for that feeling
if you didn't give money you either feel
nothing
or you feel bad you can't feel good
by not giving all right you paid for
that feeling
so now the question is how is that
person encouraging us to give
the joke is they act like every
corporation in the world
they talk about themselves me me me me
me me me right like they sit there with
their little outdoor advertising
little sign right and it says
i'm homeless i'm hungry i got 12 kids
i'm a veteran god bless they got it all
in there trying to appeal to somebody
the religious vote
the veteran vote you know the child
sympathizer
surround yourself with lots of pets go
for that one too right
all in an attempt to get something from
someone
takers not givers right all about me
well what do corporations do we've added
more ram we've added more rom we've
added more speed
this one's number one we're the biggest
we're the best we've been around since
1969. we're better than them we're
faster than them we're more efficient
than that one me me me me me me me me me
and so even if we buy their product
guess what yeah we don't really feel
much
so i did this little experiment i found
um um a nice homeless lady on the
streets of new york who's willing to
help out and i learned that with her
sign
which was pretty typical i'm homeless
i'm hungry
she makes between 20 and 30 a day
uh for you know for a day's worth of
work eight to ten hours of sitting there
selling goodwill
eight to ten hours she'll make 20 to 30
30 is considered a good day
i changed her sign and the new sign
made her 40 dollars in two hours
and then she left
[Music]
it's one of the reasons she's homeless
is because she's decided that she only
needs 20 to 30 dollars a day to live
if she stayed she would have made 150
the point is she made 40 bucks in two
hours what are the signs say the sign
said
if you only give once a month please
think of me next time
it has nothing to do with the taker it
has everything to do with the giver
and what are the objections people give
when they don't
give i can't give to everyone
how do i know that they really need it
and so i address both those concerns i
know you can't give to everyone so if
you only give once a month
my cause is legitimate i will still be
here when you're ready to give
40 bucks two hours make it about them
not about you
the fact of the matter is one hundred
percent
of customers are people and one hundred
percent of clients
are people and one hundred percent of
employees
are people i don't care how good your
product is i don't care how good your
marketing is
i don't care how good your design is if
you don't understand people you don't
understand business
we are social animals we are human
beings and our survival
depends on our ability to form trusting
relationships
do you ever watch um deadliest catch
on the discovery channel i was looking
through channels one night and deadliest
catch came on
and on this episode just random
they were in a huge storm now for those
of you who don't know deadliest catch
they take these crab fishing boats out
in the bering sea which is like
terrible and they put cameras on them
and we watch right
the reason that's i guess significant is
because these crab fishermen have i
think
one of the top five deadliest jobs in
the world
you know i don't know what the exact
number is but dozens of
fishermen die every year doing doing
this
we apparently find that entertaining
which it actually is
so they have cameras only on five or six
of the ships even though there are many
many ships that go out
fishing every season and they don't
really come into proximity with each
other
because you know the ocean's huge and
they usually sabotage each other and
give each other false information
because they're all competitors they're
all looking to
get the crabs and you know make sure
that they find them somebody else
doesn't and yeah it's business right
it's just business it's okay
we all do the same thing in our own
companies and in this one episode this
big huge storm was so violent that they
had to bring all the pots which are the
big cages that they catch the crabs and
they'd bring all the parts back on
the boat uh and wait out the storm and
just by
dumb luck one of the boats that had
cameras on it
was in proximity of a boat that didn't
have cameras on it and so they filmed
they had secured all their pots on the
deck and so they started filming the
other boat
and they filmed a guy climbing on the
outside of the cage
securing the pots and all of a sudden a
huge wave
hits the side of the boat and the guy's
not there anymore
and the people on the boat with the
cameras start screaming man overboard
man overboard man overboard
and they turn their boat towards
where they think he might be he's a
stranger they don't know him they don't
know the
the crew members of the other boat and
yet they react
and they turn towards him and they find
him in the drink
and for those of you don't understand
how dangerous this is if the water is so
cold that if you're in the water for i
think that it's a minute or a minute 30.
hypothermia will set and then you die
and
they come upon him and he's screaming
don't let me die don't let me die
and they pull him on board not out of
the woods yet
they strip off his clothes because it's
wet and cold
and they wrap blankets around him to
prevent hypothermia from setting in
and he survives and it's overwhelming
and the captain comes down
and this is all i mean you can go watch
it on tv the camera comes
the captain comes down and he hugs this
stranger
this young man his competitor he hugs
this guy as if
he's his own son i
i lost it everybody is crying
and you realize what happened here was a
human interaction
and the reason they risk their own lives
to help this other person even though
they spend every other day trying to
get ahead in sabotage is because at the
end of the day they're all crab
fishermen
and they know something about each other
and they know something about the risk
that they all take
to do this and when push comes to shove
they will put themselves out there to
help each other for no other reason
than they get it they're one of the same
i will promise you that every single
member of that crew that day went home
with a feeling of fulfillment i promise
you
that every single person on that crew
that day
felt more good in their hearts and in
their jobs
then the richest days that they've ever
pulled in
my question is is what are you doing to
help the person next to you
don't you want to wake up and go to work
for the only reason that you can do
something good for someone else
it's easy to pull things back it's very
hard to ramp things up
and i'd rather start with something
that's too big and pull it back into
reality
then start with something that's so easy
that you can't really get it
up for example you know
don't set your goals realistically set
them entirely unrealistically
i mean shoot for 80 and be disappointed
when you hit 70 as opposed to shooting
for 20 in being ecstatic when you hit
21. we beat our goal
yeah but it was a low goal you know i
think
i think to be frustrated and achieving
something
rather than ecstatic and and achieving
less
is a better way to live not to mention
you achieve more
um so uh
i'm a great believer in that the greater
good like those things are like
so big they're ridiculous i mean like
you know my goal
is a hundred year goal is called world
peace
you know so daunting
you know but that's the idea if i fail
uh
and i certainly won't achieve it in my
lifetime i like to think that what i'll
contribute towards that
ridiculous idealistic nonsense goal will
be more than if i say
if i can just be happy by myself in my
little house you know
right i mean that's nice and all but
that's good i like the idea of
contributing to your neighbor as well
you speak to businesses and companies
and leadership teams and employees and
stuff
without mentioning names i don't want to
put you on the spot but have you gone
and talked to
a company that's been in trouble and
then spoken to their team
and then checked in on them after you've
spoken to their leadership team
and what did that look like did you
notice a noticeable change
did they come to you and tell you that
this has helped our organization out and
our culture
is much improved because of it
you mean does my [ __ ] work
i mean sure
here's the problem with my stuff you got
to do it
and i am not i'm not anybody's like
you know mom or dad i'm not going to do
it for you
and i have a very lazy fair approach of
i once had a
i once had a client this was a bunch of
years ago
that said what guarantee do i have that
your stuff will work
to which my answer was none
like i i'm giving you a tool
you can it's like a hammer you can use
it broadly or narrowly you can build a
table you can build a house it's the
same tool you can use it for marketing
you can use it to
completely revitalize your entire
culture and even though i'm going to
sell you the most
beautiful hammer i'm not going to
guarantee the structural integrity of
the house
right it's your business you want to
ignore all my stuff
ignore it i don't care it's your and if
your business collapses you know what
happens to me
nothing like i don't mean to be
cold about it like of course i want the
people i work with to do well but it's
not mine it's theirs and i take no
emotional responsibility for the
decisions they make
so yes there are many people that i've
had the pleasure of working with some
who worked for dysfunctional
organizations
that went on the hard journey of
completely changing the way they lead
and completely revitalizing their
culture and it has great success
it's not because of me it's because of
them right at the same time there are
many people who came in like what an
amazing speech and did nothing
you know thanks that was great you know
and i don't
it's of course it's going to fail you
know so
i i think that we we have too much
especially in the consulting world or
the
design world everybody's so
paternalistic
about it and designers are famous for
this right they get so
personally offended when the client
chooses the wrong
thing don't you know we're trying to
help them
or who cares like it's their business
that's what you find i've i've had that
instead of arguing with somebody for
them to make the right choice
which because we genuinely want to help
them what i have found is if you push
the accountability
because when we argue we're taking
accountability this is better
this will help you we're taking
responsibility
accountability but if we say look we've
been doing this a bunch of years we know
more about design than you do
um i'm telling you for every reason that
i can
outline for you why this will help you
more but if you don't want to do it
that's fine it's your business do what
you want the minute you switch the
accountability and put it all on them
amazingly they're much more open to your
opinion
because now they're responsible
discovering your why
is just the beginning in order to enjoy
all the benefits
of having a clearly articulated why
you'll need to have the courage
and discipline to use it like thomas
edison said
vision with that execution is
hallucination
there is an ideal order for implementing
your why though sometimes reality does
get in the way
and it all starts with you our natural
tendency
is to start with the tangible we define
our value by what we do
so it takes practice to start with why
like riding a bicycle
at first we're unsure unsteady we're in
our heads
thinking about all the things we need to
do pedal fast keep enough speed so we
don't fall over
we have to really concentrate we may
even fall over
even scrape our knees but we get back on
the bike and try again
and eventually it becomes natural
starting with why is no different
at first it feels awkward it may not
even work
but with practice it will become so
natural that you won't even be able to
imagine a time when you couldn't
do it just like riding a bicycle
in time your why will act as a filter
for many of the decisions and choices
you make
it becomes a tool to help you find a job
or seize an opportunity
in which you're more likely to succeed
it removes a lot of the guessing
here's a metaphor to show you what i
mean it's called
the salary test we're constantly asking
people for their advice on what to do or
how to do it
it's like going to a dinner party and
somebody says do you know what you need
you need m ms we've done so well with m
ms you've got to use m
ms somebody else says to us rice milk in
this economy you have to use rice milk
someone else says to us kit kats you
have to use kit kats
and somebody else says to you it's all
about celery
we go to the supermarket with all this
good advice from all these smart people
with brilliant case studies
and we buy everything we buy kit kats
and m m's celery and rice milk
there's a lot of time we spend at the
supermarket and a lot of money we spend
at the supermarket
and when we get to the checkout lane
we're standing there with all these
products in our hands
and no one can see what we believe
because we bought
everything but let's imagine we know our
why
let's imagine our why is to always be
healthy and only do things that protect
the health of our bodies
now which products do we buy given all
the same advice from all the same smart
people
this time we only buy celery and we only
buy rice milk they're the only two that
makes
sense we spend less time and less money
at the supermarket
and when we're standing there in line
with only celery and only rice milk
now people can see what we believe
somebody walking past can say hey i can
see that you're healthy so am i
you just attracted an opportunity or a
referral or a friend
simply by saying and doing the things
that you believe and the best part
is it's scalable as soon as i said the
why
you knew exactly which products we were
going to buy
this means the more you can articulate
your why the more
others will know what you stand for and
will be able to help you make the right
decisions
from now on you will work to ensure
everything you do
is a good fit if you do too many things
that aren't a good fit
you'll feel uncomfortable and people
will feel that you're being inauthentic
on the other hand when you start with
why your ability
to stand out find support and work to
all your natural strengths will flourish
with practice you will learn to trust
your why you will eventually start to
see your job and the things you do
as ways to breathe life into your cause
what do good leaders have in common
um they have the courage to do the right
thing
um they're people of high character and
high integrity
but for me the big one is courage it's
it's very hard to be a leader it's hard
to speak truth to power very often
you might be the one that gets in
trouble or lose your job
it's hard to do the right thing it's
much easier to do
the expedient thing and um
and it's also a huge undertaking to be a
leader every every moment of every day
it's
kind of like being a parent so i was
watching the olympics this last summer
olympics
and i was amazed at how bad the
questions were that the reporters would
ask
all the athletes and almost always they
asked the same question
whether they were about to compete or
after they competed
were you nervous right and
to a t all the athletes went no
right and what i realized is it's not
that they're not nervous it's their
interpretation of what's happening in
their bodies i mean what happens when
you're nervous
right your heart rate starts to go
you're you know you sort of get a little
tense you get a little sweaty
right you have expectation of what's
coming and we interpreted that as i'm
nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing it's the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
olympic quality athletes
have learned to interpret the stimuli
that the rest of us would say as
nervous as excited they all say the same
thing no i'm not nervous
i'm excited and so i've actually
practiced it
just to tell myself when i start to get
nervous that this is excitement
yeah you know and so where when you i
used to speak in front of a large
audience and somebody would say how do
you feel i should say
a little nervous now when somebody says
how do you feel i'm like
really excited actually and it it came
from just sort of telling myself
no no this is excitement and it becomes
a little bit automatic later on
um but it's kind of a remarkable thing
to deal with pressure by interpreting
what your body is experiencing as
excitement rather than
nerves and it's really kind of effective
it makes you want to rush forward rather
than pull back and yet it's the same
experience
the game of business is
an infinite game right it obeys all the
rules
um there are known and unknown players
you don't know
all the competitors necessarily in one
industry to another
the rules are changeable we haven't all
agreed what the rules are
and there is no winning the game of
business
right the game just perpetuates in fact
the game of business has existed longer
than every single company on the planet
today and it will outlast
every single commodore company on the
planet today if you look at the dow
index
of 30 something odd companies that make
up the dow index something like 70 or 80
percent
of those companies are 35 years or
younger
right so it gets me thinking if you
listen
to the language that companies use
they don't know what game they're in
they talk about being number one
talk about beating their competition
based on what agreed upon
criteria based on what agreed upon time
frame
is it market share is it profits is it
revenues
square footage number of employees over
what one month
five months six months a year five years
ten years the life of the company
i haven't agreed to those rules and so
companies can arbitrarily declare
themselves number one in anything they
want
if they set the standards and the time
frames and the only reason we do these
things on annualized basis we tend to
we tend to compare ourselves to other
organizations annually
is only because we pay taxes annually if
we pay taxes every 18 months that would
be sort of the standard
but again we still haven't agreed what
the metrics are to be number one
that means the companies that are
playing the infinite game
are playing against most of the others
who are playing the finite game means
those finite companies find themselves
in quagmire almost every single
bankruptcy not almost every every single
bankruptcy
is a company that's run out of the will
or the resources to play they drop out
of the game the game will persist
another company will fill their space
it's not like it's not like the business
stops or the industry ends
and uh the companies that are playing
the infinite game will frustrate
those finite players which i absolutely
adore
so i spoke at an education summit for
microsoft i also spoke at an education
summit for apple
now i would say about 70 to 80 percent
of the executives at microsoft spent
about 70 to 80 percent of their
power points talking about how to beat
apple at the apple summit
100 of the executives spent 100
of their presentations talking about how
to help teachers teach and how to help
students learn
one was obsessed with their journey with
their vision with their cause
the other one was obsessed with their
competition guess who's stuck in
quagmire
guess who's frustrated by their
competition
i'll tell you another story it's a
personal story
it's not one that i share very often and
it profoundly changed
the course of my life
in august of 2011
i had the opportunity to visit
afghanistan
with the united states air force i had
done some work with the mobility forces
these the people that fly the tankers
and the cargo planes and air force one
all the big planes and the general said
to me
simon you've gotten to know us quite
well it would mean a lot to me
if you would go to either iraq or
afghanistan
to see our men and women perform their
mission
would you be willing to go so i said yes
they picked afghanistan now i didn't
tell my parents where i was going
because i didn't want them to worry i
told them i was going
away with the air force true i told them
i was going
to be out of touch for a while because i
was going to be on a lot of planes
true i told them i was going to germany
true i just didn't tell them from
germany i was going to afghanistan
and i had no responsibility i was simply
going as an observer
i had two officers who were assigned to
be my escorts
and we met basically for the first time
uh at penn station in philadelphia
where we drove to dover air force base
where we would leave for germany we took
a big c5 cargo plane
in germany we changed planes and we got
on a kc-135 tanker
built in 1956.
i was on a plane built in 1956
where we flew to bagram we landed in the
middle
of the night we touched down
and the big door in the side of the
plane had opened but we hadn't gotten
off the plane yet we'd been on the
we'd been on the ground for maybe 10
minutes and the base came under rocket
attack
three rockets hit a hundred yards off
our nose this is how my
trip began now if you've ever been in a
war zone for those of you
in the room who've ever been in a war
zone you have you know this
you have all the feelings you're
supposed to have you just don't have
them at the right times
weirdly i was incredibly relaxed and
maybe that's because the people i was
with were incredibly
relaxed and i felt safe we revenge the
panic came later
we're eventually given the all clear and
we went to our
housing now the purpose of being in
afghanistan we were going to be in the
country for up to 30 hours and the goal
was to witness an airdrop mission
they're not regularly scheduled so we
had to find out if there was one as soon
as we got there and it turns out there
was one first thing in the morning
so we got about two and a half hours
three hours of sleep
and we went and got on this airdrop
mission which was incredible we sat in
the back of a c-17
we flew about an hour and a half two
hours out to the middle of nowhere
afghanistan
the plane dropped down to about 2000
feet the back door
opened and we sat there and watched as
cargo flew out the back
so we could resupply an army forward
operating base it was an amazing amazing
experience
we then flew back to bagram and the goal
was to come back home
there's no regularly scheduled flight so
we have to sort of find out what flights
we can get on and it's always up to the
discretion of the pilots we found a
flight that was leaving
shortly after we got back and so we
asked the pilots and they said
absolutely we can join their flight and
we waited and waited and waited and
waited and waited and waited and
eventually we got on the plane we were
all strapped in
literally five minutes from leaving and
the pilot walked up to us and said
i'm sorry we need to bump you guys we
need to make more room for stretchers
it was carrying wounded warriors out of
out of theater and they needed our space
if there's ever a good reason to get
bumped off a plane this was it
so we got off the plane and we went to
look for another flight
and that's when we found out there were
no other flights until tuesday
and this was only saturday i was gonna
get stuck in afghanistan for at least
four days maybe longer because we don't
know
what we're gonna get on on tuesday and i
have no way of telling my parents
they're not gonna hear from me on the
date that i told them that i would get
home
immediately every fiber of my being sank
and i remember becoming completely
panicked
and completely preoccupied with one
thing
my happiness my safety and my comfort
and i didn't care who had to go out of
their way to get me what i wanted
i remember there was a public affairs
officer who said i can get you to
kyrgyzstan but you don't have the right
visa and i looked at him and i said you
get me on that plane
i don't talk to people like that and i
could see myself becoming this person
that i it some of us in the room have
worked for somebody
in our careers who wants the next
promotion
and they don't care that they have to
tie our turn our lives upside down so
they can get what they want i was
becoming that person
we went back to our housing and i lay
down on the bed and closed my eyes
my mind was racing i was convinced that
there would be another rocket attack
on the base i was convinced that i was
going to get hit i was convinced that my
parents
were gonna find out that i was in
afghanistan when an arm an air force
officer
knocks on the door i was convinced
paranoia
fear everything that you can imagine
swept over me
one of the officers that i was traveling
with said i'm gonna see if i can get us
on another flight and he left
the room the other officer thinking i
was asleep
just because my eyes were closed said
well i'm going to go to the gym then
and he walked out and turned off the
lights for me i couldn't sleep my mind
was racing all i wanted to do was get
out of there i regretted saying yes i
regretted being there i didn't want to
be there
i'm in the purpose business i write and
talk about this
sense of why and sense of purpose in our
lives so i started to remind myself
simon
you need a purpose you don't have a
purpose you need a purpose so i started
inventing one
you're here to tell their story it
worked for like a few minutes and it
would slide back into my
fear and panic again and i realized what
was happening to me
is i was living the equivalent of an
unfulfilled life
compressed into 24 hours i had an
amazing day
i got to see something that most people
will never get to see in their entire
lives
except i didn't want to wake up and do
it again the next day
and i think many of us do the same thing
we can
we confuse moments of happiness
with joy and fulfillment we confuse
winning a piece of business getting a
promotion getting an award getting
recognition
doing well on a test with actual deep
fulfillment those experiences are
wonderful
but happiness is fleeting there's not a
single person in this room
absolutely zero who's walking around
with an amazing sense of accomplishment
for that test that you aced a year ago
that feeling is gone
fulfillment is something entirely
different it's something you carry with
you on a daily
basis whether you're enjoying the day or
not
it's like loving your family you may not
like your family every day but you love
your family every day
one is fleeting the other is lasting
and this is what was happening to me i
realized that i had this amazing day and
i was confusing
happiness and fulfillment and so i gave
up i lay in that bed
paranoid scared and depressed and i
literally
gave up i decided that
if i was going to get stuck here i might
as well make myself useful
and so i decided i was going to
volunteer i would speak anywhere they
wanted me to speak
i would carry boxes and sweep floors all
i wanted to do was
serve some of those amazing people that
i'd met on this trip i wanted to serve
those who served others
and instantly this incredible calm came
over me
i was even excited
this is what fulfillment means it's not
the fleeting joys that we may experience
it's not the accomplishments that we
achieve it's the opportunity to serve
those
who serve others and upon making this
realization i had nothing but joy
and calm and excitement and peace
it was like a movie the timing was
uncanny
upon making this amazing realization the
door flung open
and it was major throch morton he said i
got us on a flight there's been a flight
that's been redirected but we have to go
now we have to go now if we don't leave
now
they're going to leave without us
where's matt i said he's at the gym
so we ran to the gym we got him off the
treadmill we ran back
no time to shower he put his uniform
back on we grabbed all our stuff
and we ran out to the flight line when
we got out to the flight line we could
see the plane we were going to go
we were going to take home see big c-17
it was sitting right out there on the
tarmac
and as soon as we got there a security
cordon came down and they wouldn't let
us out to the plane
because somewhere else on base they were
having a fallen soldier ceremony
and out of respect when they have the
fallen soldiers ceremony
everything stops and so so we we sat on
the curb and waited
and i told the guys what i had gone
through in the bed just moments ago
and i cried like a baby and this is one
of the things a lot of people don't
realize about the military
crying is just fine
those guys kept me safe not just
physically they made me feel safe
and i felt totally comfortable telling
them what i was going through and how i
felt
eventually this security cordon came up
and they let us out to the plane
we would be the only three passengers
aboard this plane
other than the crew what i didn't tell
you
is the reason the flight was redirected
is because we would be carrying home the
fallen soldier
for whom they just had the ceremony
the army brought the flag-draped casket
on board all the air force crew stood in
the line at perfect attention
i'm a civilian i put my hand on my heart
i felt kind of stupid
so i stood at attention with the air
force
crew as the army laid the casket in the
middle of the aircraft
they hold it a very slow eight-count
salute
they marched off the plane and we
watched them hugging and crying
as they walked away the crew got to work
strapping this precious cargo down
we then had a nine and a half hour
overnight flight back to germany
where i slept right next to this casket
on every other plane i went on we talked
we joked barely a word was
spoken in nearly ten hours on every
other flight i visited the cockpit and
hung out with the crew i didn't visit
the cockpit once
and i'll tell you it was one of the
greatest honors of my life having just
gone through this
incredibly strange experience on the
ground i had the honor of bringing home
somebody who understands service
much deeper than i will ever understand
it
serve those who serve others and you
will live
a life of joy and fulfillment
i went to see a play with a friend of
mine who is an actor
and the play was awful
uh i mean
a train wreck the script was awful the
directing was awful i mean it was an
absolute train wreck
the question you asked was about
collaboration right should any of those
actors have taken the part
now of course if you're going to take
apart because you need an extra cash
a little extra cash or you want to get a
little extra practice
then you have to do so i think knowing
i'm doing this for the money
or i'm doing this just to keep keep my
my my skills sharp
but i'm under no illusion that this is
something that i connect with but i'm
gonna do the best that i can
and then don't lie to yourself you know
the other problem is don't do that too
often because that'll just destroy any
passion that you have for your medium
right and i think and we've talked about
this which is
which is any artist any person but
especially artists
have to know their why you have to know
why you're showing up
in the first place and you have to be
able to talk about it
because if you talk about it things
happen people go
i like you right now you may not get the
part but you're more likely to find
people who want to work with you even if
you're not the most talented one who
auditioned
this is my career by the way right when
i
learned to talk about what i believed
i didn't talk about the things i've done
i didn't talk about the parts i've had
or the shows i've been in or who trained
me
or the schools i went to resume resume
resume
i started i learned to talk about what i
believed
and some people thought it was cheesy
they didn't call me back
good and some people went that's great
and i was not the most talented not the
most experienced
not the best at my field but because
they stood for or believed in what i
stood for they wanted to work with me
they would rather work with someone who
understood them who got them
more than somebody who would just take
orders and do exactly what they wanted
regardless of facility there's a paradox
being a human being
um unfortunately at all times every
moment of every day we are both
individuals
and members of groups right we are both
responsible for ourselves and our own
happiness and our own joy
but at the same time we're members of
families we're members of churches we're
members of teams we're members of
companies
like we're members of multiple groups
every single day at every moment
and this produces some complications we
have to make decisions
so do we put ourselves first or do we
put the group first and there's a debate
some people say oh you have to take care
of yourself before you can take care of
the group
and some say no no you take care of the
group and that's what helps they will
take care of you and the answer is yes
it's not one or the other it's actually
both simultaneously
it is a challenge but at the end of the
day there's no getting around it
as social animals our success our
happiness our joy our ability to get
anything
done requires help and
those who embrace the fact that they
cannot do everything alone
that they need the support and love and
it doesn't mean somebody who's
physically helping you live something
sometimes it might be someone who just
believes in you these things are
essential and there's just no getting
around it
the next part is a worthy rival
now i said before that the only true
competitor in an
uh an infinite game is yourself this is
true what your competition does
is it helps reveal to you your
weaknesses
admire the others in your organization
not to beat them there's no such thing
not to be number one there's no such
thing but if somebody else is better
than you
at something that means you have to go
work harder yourself
it's like running in a race if you're
driven to be number one
if you're driven to make the most money
if you're driven to show up in some
arbitrary ranking that you don't even
have a say in
that's like tripping the the next runner
you will win the race
but you're still a slow runner rather
fall behind this year and then you work
and work and work because ultimately the
goal is not to be number one this year
the goal is to create an organization
that will outlast every single one of
you
this is about building strong
foundations this is about
looking long-term in the short term
money is simply fuel to
to to make the car go
we don't own cars to buy more fuel
we own cars to go somewhere it's the
same thing in an organization your
organization exists to advance something
the money is simply there to make a go
and i fear
that what has happened in the university
system is similar to what i'm seeing
in business it's similar to what i'm
seeing in politics
it's similar to what i'm seeing in
hospitals
which is an over the sense of excessive
pressure
to bring money in at the expense of
something else
there's an excessive amount of
short-termism and
massive amounts of rationalizing this is
just the game
we just have to do it if we don't
somebody else will
the obsession with getting grants
meaning you're hiring people who are
more likely to help you get a grant
even though they're teaching things that
we don't necessarily even need or want
that's called short-termism so i'm a
huge modern dance
lover like that's the thing i love and
i don't go to the joyce anymore because
everything that they have on their stage
is good it's good
everything is safe to me they put things
on their stage that's good they sell
tickets
nothing's bad and nothing's great
it's all good i don't go anymore i go to
bam a lot
i have seen things that have profoundly
changed my view of the world and i have
walked
out of more things at bam
literally i'm like i'm done and my
friend's like you can't i'm like we can
you know i have walked outs out of
so many things at bam and yet i continue
to go and continue to go and i continue
to go because i know what they stand for
that's my preference i'm not saying it's
right or wrong i'm saying that's my
preference
that i would rather take the risk of
walking out
knowing that i might get moved in a way
that i've never experienced before
more than just going to have a nice
night out and see something that i know
is good
right and i think that goes for our
careers as well
you know which is if you choose to be
the kind of artist
that stands for something that you want
to be yourself and bring yourself into
everything that you do you will get
fewer parts
you will the parts you get
will move you in a way that most artists
will not get moved
or you can bend and manipulate yourself
a little bit and
sort of be a little bit more of what
they want
and play their role and even though you
don't really buy into it
it's a part and i want to be an actor i
want to be a performer i'm going to i'm
going to do what they want
you will absolutely get more parts
without a doubt
you will you will can arguably have a
better career
but will you be profoundly moved as an
artist the odds are lower it's not i
can't say
never it's just the odds are lower it's
not
better or worse it is simply the
decision
on how you choose to manage or lead your
own career
both are acceptable right one means you
get to use your facility a lot
one means you get to work a lot one
means you might be able to do only your
art and actually make a living
one means that you're going to be
meeting a lot of people and the odds are
that you will connect with somebody at
some point
or you choose this route
which is much more difficult and is
fraught with much
more risk and much more struggle
but you become known for the thing that
you are
the word entrepreneur is bandied about
too loosely
that not everyone who owns a small
business as an entrepreneur
there are small business owners and
they're entrepreneurs what's an
entrepreneur and you can find
entrepreneurs in big companies
it doesn't mean that they're small
business owners right i think
entrepreneurs are problem solvers
i think rather than risk takers yeah i
think fundamentally there are plenty of
risk takers i think who
are an entrepreneur there's a risk taker
of your small business owner right
you went out to start the business but
they're not the same i don't think
um and entrepreneurs are those ones who
they're constantly looking to solve
problems and that's where i think they
perceive opportunity or the mischief
that you describe
i don't think it's i don't think
inherently it's a sense of mischief
they're not trying to
stir the pot for the sake of stirring
the pot i think that they see something
and they're like
we can make that better or we can fill
that hole and that's very much the way
the famous entrepreneurs the elon musks
and the richard bransons operate
they see gaps they see things that don't
work as their jobs
as did jobs they see things that could
be better are they
i mean elon musk was just interviewed by
chris anderson at ted last week
and uh chris anderson sort of near the
end of the interview it's online
go watch it it's really great um
uh chris anderson asks elon musk
something to the effect of
why why are you doing all these things
like why don't you just stick with tesla
and be done with it like why do all the
other stuff and you look at and musk
you can see this look on his face and he
takes a long time to answer he actually
doesn't understand the question
he cannot understand why you wouldn't do
that
and he sort of gets emphatic which elon
musk is pretty amazing because he
doesn't get emphatic
but that's basically what it is he gets
emphatic and says because i want to live
in a world that's better than this
or words to that effect you know where i
am not where the world that we're living
right now makes us unhappy why don't we
want to live in a world that makes us
happy
you know he gets sort of he can't
understand and again it's vision first
and that's why he doesn't understand why
you wouldn't try and solve problems i'm
a lover of creative people
um and so any sort of expression of
of of how you see the world in with
different terminology is fascinating to
me
and so even though i myself i'm a
photographer um
so i have that visual aspect i'm a huge
fan of modern dance and spend a lot of
time
sort of with dancers and in the dance
world and have you know
tried my hand at choreography just to
see you know
i'm not good but it i i like the idea of
trying it you know
um and uh and so for me it's about
perspective
which is when i when when you hang out
with dancers and you you know you sort
of learn to dance a little bit or you
learn to choreograph a little bit or you
learn to paint a little bit you know
i'm not a painter but i painted a
painting recently you know
um you know if you if you unders it's
like chaos theory
you know everything's connected right
you know it's like we we conveniently
divide up our lives like here's my
personal life here's my professional
life i'm
you know here's my social life i'm
looking to find balance it's just you
you know and all the same things apply
and so if you're if you're good here you
can apply what you learn here to there
you know and so when you when you learn
how things interconnect and
and people interconnect and how human
relationships work and presence
i mean you want to learn about presence
take a dance class you learn all about
how to present yourself and be forwards
you know take an acting class learn how
to you know present your speech people
say simon how'd you learn this is like
i'm exposed to all of this so the tools
i've learned have just
mainly been different perspectives on
how other people use their creative
talents to see the world and if i can
get little pieces of those
they they help me in many many different
ways imagine we're standing
in a big empty room right and we're
standing in one corner and i give you a
simple instruction
i want you to go to that corner in a
straight line
right off you go no big deal right
without telling you
i slip a chair in front of you what do
you do
you go around the chair now you just
disobeyed what i told you to do i told
you to go to that corner straight line
but this is the amazing things about
human beings which is when we're given a
clear destination
we use our own creativity and our own
sense of innovation and our own
problem-solving abilities
to overcome obstacles to get to the
destination in other words the
destination is more important than the
route
right we are flexible about the route we
are obsessed with the destination
reset we're standing in the corner
together and i give you a simple
instruction
go somewhere in this room in a straight
line and you say to me where do you want
me to go i'm like i don't know
you're smart figure it out go in a
straight line and so you pick a point
and you start walking
and without telling you i put a chair in
front of you and what do you do you come
to a grinding halt
and i say what did you stop for you go
will you put a chair in front of me
or you'll make a sudden turn and go in
another direction
right and this is the problem it's the
same obstacle
the difference is when you have a clear
set at a clear destination the obstacles
become
easy to overcome when you don't have a
clear destination you keep coming to a
grinding halt and what we do in our
companies
is we're counting the steps we're taking
along the route but we're never looking
at the destination
right so company says made a million
dollars this year we were only planning
on making eight hundred thousand like we
took ten steps we're only planning on
taking eight
where are you going no clue right
we count the steps and so the point is
is that people want to feel that the
effort that they're exerting
actually are moving somewhere and so
successful measurement successful
recognition is not just for the steps
you take
it's not just for the effort it's that
the effort you exerted moved us
closer to where we're trying to get to
and that get to should be some crazy
ideal
my ideal is to live in a world in which
the vast majority of people wake up
every single morning
you know inspired to go to work and
fulfilled by the work that they do and
the
the couple of measurements that i use
are if the book is selling and i by the
way people ask me how many have you sold
i have no clue
i've never asked the publisher because i
don't care i really don't care how many
i've sold what i care about is the
amazon rankings and that those are going
steady or up and not plummeting because
that means
other people right because i don't have
a publicist i don't have a marketing
strategy on purpose i didn't hire one of
those companies
to sell the book for me and the reason
is is because i'm not interested in book
sales
i'm interested in the spreading of an
idea and so i just use that as a metric
to help me understand
am i sort of marching in the because the
more i preach
is it resonating you know and so you
have a couple of these
imperfect measurements that help you
understand are you going along the way
so it's not just great effort look what
you achieved
because that's what we're doing now
right our goal is to increase top line
revenues by 50 million dollars
for what reason right which is we have
to know the destination
and then we say amazing
you took us that much closer and if we
go to the right it's because we were
overcoming an obstacle
if we hadn't gone to the right we would
have been stuck forever
thank you you know it's not always
straight lines
it's not always straight lines but it's
it's in one direction
rarely are we instant experts you may
have a particular gift
or um affinity towards something but you
still get better
you know people would pay me high
compliments when i started speaking
and then people who've seen me a year or
two later say that i'm even better and i
feel it
uh why is that because you you you learn
more
you know i think that hubris is
dangerous i think to think that you're
an expert in anything
is a is a foolish pursuit um you're
never
you're never as good as you could be
there's always room for improvement
there's always room to get better um you
don't that doesn't mean you have to
listen to all the advice
um just you know not necessarily does
everybody know best
but but to believe that you can be
better
and to believe that you can offer more
um is a constant pursuit um
you know i used to think being a public
speaker meant being poised and
presenting in a way that was compelling
and speaking at the right pace and
that's
that's a part of it um but
but i um have been taking more risks
lately doing things that are
very unstructured and very uncomfortable
and i will now do like if i have an hour
to speak i'd rather speak for 20 minutes
and do 40 minutes worth of questions
and who knows how that's gonna go and
that to me is the best
and so i'm a better speaker because now
i'm way more open to the unknown
where a few years ago that that would
have scared me
the biggest lesson i learned was thank
goodness i learned it pretty early on
which is and i think a lot of business
owners make this mistake
which is uh because i was the boss you
know in my own mind
yeah um uh i thought i had to know all
the answers
and if i didn't i thought i had to
pretend that i did
and uh that's stupid
um and what i learned is that
just because i may have the the top
position in the hierarchy
i i'm not expected to know everything
and if i pretend to know everything
it diminishes the value of all the great
ideas and the great
intelligence around me and when things
got difficult i would never admit it
right i would just put on a brave face
and show up every day and
um and the the biggest lesson i learned
was to say i don't know i don't
understand or i need help
um at any level about any subject yeah
and
amazingly i was always surrounded by
people who wanted to help or who knew
answers but they never offered to help
or
offer the answers because they didn't
think i needed it because i kept
pretending that i knew it all
right not to mention the fact that
nobody likes a no at all um
so that was huge for me and when i was
willing to ask for help and
accept it when it was offered and and
sort of accept the humility
of the fact that other people know a lot
more about
a lot of things than i know i know one
thing
you know and they know lots of things um
uh that's when things really started to
move because we were now a team
like we were actually working together
and how are people i see a lot of
questions here around dealing with a
negative team
or dealing with a team where we feel
people may not have the right intentions
or the right motives
how do people work with that the viewers
are asking yeah it happens
um and the answer is don't worry about
it like we can't obsess
about the ones that are doing something
wrong we obsess about the ones that are
doing something right instead of
criticizing the ones that are
negative we want to build up and
complement the ones that are positive
because when that's the reward structure
which is finding
and identifying and rewarding good
then everybody wants to be rewarded and
recognized and so eventually the
behavior comes in as opposed to
criticizing wrong nobody wants to be
criticized and all it does is it makes
people back away and afraid
so the point is ignore the negativity
and focus on the positivity and start
obsessing about the people that are
doing something right
i learned this lesson the hard way um i
wrote a blog
and we had a uh uh somebody write in
with a very aggressive
sort of note to me and sort of saying
i'm a hypocrite and all of this stuff
and my team got together and we
discussed our response and somebody
wrote back and
he rebecca very nasty response back we
thought okay how do we react to this
and i eventually got on the phone with
him and tried to talk with him and they
talked him off the shelf and talked
about the
you know it was okay and about six
months later i wrote another blog
and he wrote another and we got together
and it occurred to us
we were spending all of this time with
one
negative person yeah and we were
ignoring all of the people who wrote in
compliments and were supporting our work
and so we literally made a decision that
day
that when we got results like that we
wouldn't care
and that if we were going to invest any
time of our people it was going to be to
say thank you
to the people who were helping us and
helping compliment us
and helping advance the message and so
we don't i personally don't respond to
those
at all anymore ever but i regularly
call people up to say thank you for
helping advance the cause
and it feels nicer and there's time
better spent and we're not wasting time
anyway so yeah focus on the positive how
would someone know
if they're doing something for their why
how do you know
oh you can feel it you feel it you ever
had that experience
where um you feel like something's wrong
you know sort of you're like you make a
decision but it makes you uncomfortable
you're not you're not following through
with your cause or your purpose and you
ever have a decision where everybody's
like you're crazy you're crazy like this
just feels like the most natural normal
thing
i could do i'm not even in doubt here
you know right now
the problem with simply running on gut
is it's not scalable
this is the reason we want to learn our
why learn to articulate and be able to
speak
our why so that others can understand
why we're making the decisions we're
making because the problem is if you
only trust your gut to those around you
sometimes it does appear that we're
crazy or unfocused
and so people leave us and don't help us
because they think we're nuts
the minute we can articulate and speak
that why with clarity that others can
understand
then not only will they have context for
the decisions we're making
but they'll rally to help us and even do
things that we didn't even ask because
they understand
the higher purpose that we're trying to
advance so
you just know it's a terrible answer um
but you can feel it and this is where
joy and fulfillment in our work come
from which is different from happiness
you can win a big client get a promotion
get a raise happy
you know do a good job produce something
great happy
but that feeling dissipates it doesn't
last for
you know it certainly doesn't last for
months or years it might last for days
or weeks
right that that immensely happy feeling
that we all have that big client we won
or that big promotion we got
is now gone joy fulfillment
which doesn't mean that we love every
day but joy and fulfillment comes from
that feeling that every day our work is
contributing to something bigger
and that's that's way more important so
the infinite game exists up here
finite game exists down here right the
infinite game
is includes the why what i call our
purpose cause or belief
it's the vision of the company it's
where we're going it's something that we
will never practically reach
in our lifetimes or ever but we will die
trying that's
the point right it's different from a
big hairy audacious goal which for all
practical purposes you could reach it
may be difficult but you could
reach it this is an ideal something
it's a vision of the world so my vision
i imagine a world
in which the vast majority of people
wake up every single morning inspired to
go to work
feel safe when they're there and return
home fulfilled at the end of the day
that is my vision
right we will never practically get
there but we will die trying
the united states was founded with a
document called the declaration of
independence
in which the document's stated all men
are created equal
now the united states has not achieved
that and will never achieve that
but it the country is at its best when
we're trying to achieve that civil
rights
women's suffrage gay rights the you know
universal
education universal healthcare etc etc
this is where our values exist
our values are timeless they do not
change every year whenever we have a
strategic offsite and if they do
you have a problem that happens in big
companies
every few years a new ceo comes in and
they have a values thing and they change
and they change and they change no no
your values are your values
right and they're based on your founders
and they exist
from patterns of how you operate when
you are operating at your natural best
when your company is operating at its
natural best when all cylinders are
firing when you're in the flow whatever
euphemism you want to use
there is a pattern that emerges and that
pattern are your values there's a
minimum of three there's no more than
five
if there's more than five there's
usually redundancy you can find overlap
that you can find lowest common
denominators
and they are intractable these things
are inherently intangible
and hard to measure right
which is why they often get brushed
aside it's not that they don't exist
they're just hard to measure
then down here you have the finites what
i call the what it's all the tangible
stuff
right things like our interests exist
down here
because they are tangible they are
inherently easy to see
and easy to measure like products sold
money taken in things like that right
number of clients we have
the way you build an infinite business
is you want to run all decisions
first through your values and your cause
and
then through your interests that's how
it works
i've become very very interested in the
idea
of playing in games that have no finish
lines
right some games have finish lines
right baseball football right
um getting a part is the finish line you
audition
there's a beginning middle and end
there's rehearsal and practice
there's uh uh uh showing up for the
audition
and you either win or you lose and then
it's over
it's over right that is finite but one's
career
is infinite there's there's no end it's
like
our lives are finite but life is
infinite
people come and people go but life
continues right theater
actors come and actors go but theater
continues it's infinite you don't win
theater
you win a part but what happens once you
get the part
the the finite game is over now you
enter the infinite game you have to be
able to convert
right and the reason this is important
and i've seen this
unfortunately so many times from a young
age all you wanted to do was
get to broadway and then you get to
broadway
and then what you've devoted your entire
life to one finite goal and when you get
there
the immediate response is depression
because i spent
15 years of my life for this one thing
and i got it
and now i don't know what to do next
like what a
get to broadway again doesn't have the
same ambition
it doesn't have the same passion you
know you've devoted you're from
you know you're from fargo north dakota
and that's all you wanted to do is get
out of fargo and make it to broadway and
you made it
right it doesn't have the same kind of
passion and this is because these are
finite goals
there's a lot of studies that have been
done
with athletes who have finite goals
to become the greatest ex in the world
right
so andre agassi was one of these one of
these athletes he wanted to become the
greatest tennis player that ever lived
guess what
everyone in his life he would he would
view them through how do you help me
get to that everything was how does this
help me get to that
everything was a transaction to how do
you help me move to there and then you
know what happens he achieved it he
became the greatest tennis player
in the world and you know what happened
immediately after depression
michael phelps set out to become the
most
meddled olympian in history do you know
what he achieved it you know what
happened immediately after
depression they spend their whole life
working for one goal though most will
never get it the few that do
don't know what to do next because their
goals were finite
their goals were finite right and so
there are finite components to your
career
but your career should be infinite
so yes of course you have to win the
finite game you have to get the part
but immediately when you get the part
now you convert to infinite you also
mention
in military we're willing to sacrifice
ourselves for the gain of others
right but in business we're willing to
sacrifice others for our own gain
yes how do you build that military
mindset in companies like here or
other companies leadership i mean it's
it's leadership creates an environment
and it's i mean this is what i learned
the the the whole concept of leadership
last and those lessons that i learned
from spending time
with folks in uniform um it was born out
of my own
experience where i i was going through a
point of my career as my career was
growing
all of a sudden you have new friends
that i didn't have before
and and that's wonderful and then i
learned the hard way that they weren't
my friends they were playing me
they wanted access or a deal or
something right and i
and i i learned it the hard way and so i
retreated i was like i wanted to be
friends with nobody else but the people
i knew way back when
which is also not a good way to live and
yet simultaneously i'm spending time
with
tons of folks in the military who you
know in business we have colleagues and
co-workers in the military of brothers
and sisters
and that's a different kind of
relationship and as you know i have
hugged more people in uniform than i've
ever hugged in suits
i've cried with more people in uniform
than i've ever cried with in suits i've
stood in the audience and listened to
officers give talks and i've sat in the
audience and cried i've never cried with
any ceo game
gave a speech ever right so there's a
different nature of relationship and my
original conclusion
was they're better people that the
reason you get a disproportionate amount
of these
kinds of behaviors is because they're
better people
and better people are drawn to a life of
service in the military which is why
we find a disproportionately high number
of them there and the more i started to
learn the more i realized i was
completely wrong
it's the environment it's the
environment and when the leader creates
an environment
in which people feel that someone has my
back they will do extraordinary things
and what i learned is that courage is
not this deep down internal fortitude
right
it comes externally it's like a trapeze
artist would never try a brand new death
defying act
unless they had a net the courage didn't
come from
the trapeze artist the courage came from
the net and it's the same
in the military which is especially when
you're in life and death situations when
you're
when you're when you're in theater
people who you don't like you still rely
on to save your life and the reason it
works is because you don't have to look
behind your shoulder
and that mentality and you know better
than anybody
which is when you when you are deployed
into dangerous
places nobody sort of loves deployment
but people have
warm feelings towards deployment which
is really strange
and suicides rarely happen in
in combat situations they usually happen
back home
and it's the intensity of the
relationships that create that warmth
and the sort of weird enjoyment of
really bad
uncomfortable and dangerous
circumstances
it's because this we're human beings and
human beings as social animals
feel our safest when we trust each other
and good leaders are capable of
producing that so
great businesses look very much like
well-run military organizations and you
know those poorly run military
organizations as well
but great businesses look exactly the
same where the leaders
give the glory they distribute authority
they push it down the ranks
let people make decisions if they screw
up there's no risk of getting fired
if the company misses its arbitrary
projections on its arbitrary date we do
not use the people to balance the books
we figure out other ways or we even
invite the people to help solve the
problems
these are the things that produce that
circle of safety that produces the exact
same outcome where people will love each
other
cry for each other sacrifice for each
other you see it in business
plenty but it always boils down
to leadership now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule
in what day what time and what place
you're going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through
so in the comments below write down your
single biggest takeaway as well as your
specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
elon musk was just interviewed by chris
anderson at ted last week
and chris anderson sort of near the end
of the interview it's online
go watch it it's really great um
uh chris anderson asks elon musk
something to the effect of
why why are you doing all these things
like why don't you just stick with tesla
and be done with it like why do all the
other stuff and you look at
and musk you can see this look on his
face and he takes a long time to answer
he actually doesn't understand the
question
he cannot understand why you wouldn't do
that
and he sort of gets emphatic which elon
musk is pretty amazing because he
doesn't get emphatic
but that's basically what it is he gets
emphatic and says because i want to live
in a world that's better than this
or words to that effect you know where i
am not where the world that we're living
right now makes us unhappy why don't we
want to live in a world that makes us
happy
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days click the link below
me and if you want three hours of
brendon burchard
inspiration check the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy them
continue to believe i'll see you there